Hey
[Music]
[Applause]
okay Thank You Ted thank you brandy
thank you to Seema and thank each and
every one of you for being here I think
I'm doing this right okay it's kind of
close enough okay only ask a couple of
questions so I know who I'm speaking to
how many of you are already using
youngevity products raise your hand okay
90 percent of you all right how many of
you have heard me lecture live before
okay good half and so I do have to go a
little slowly well for those of you
haven't heard me speak live before well
how many of you hear me on the radio
how many listen to me on the right okay
good the other half that's just good
the thing that makes my view different
on health is that I have a degree in
agriculture from years of Missouri I'm a
veterinarian from the University of
Missouri and I wrote the first paper on
a mass die-off in America from pollution
has never been written up before here in
America and I was lucky enough to run
into that event and I got it written up
and that would direct the rest of my
scientific life that was in 1962 became
a compare two pathologists as Ted
alluded to and it worked with Marlin
Perkins me old Mitchell Omaha Wild
Kingdom show some year old enough
remember that he is before the Crocodile
Hunter for younger ones
okay and the thing that I was able to do
in that project with Washington
University in st. Louis was to do these
autopsies on both humans and animals and
one project that one project over 20,000
autopsies when over 454 species of
animals and 3,000 humans for comparison
there's over 10 million chemistry's that
many slides with special stains
in the book that came out of it's 1,200
pages and it's in the Smithsonian
Institute as a national treasure it will
probably never be repeated because the
expense today would be over a billion
dollars for that project well make a
long story short became a nature public
physician 1978 and I've been treating my
patients like dogs ever since and they
get better the reason why I say that is
the animal industry we don't have health
insurance there's a huge advantage to
veterinarians not to have health
insurance for animals because when you
have health insurance the concern of the
doctor is to get the health insurance
when you don't have health insurance and
let's say it's a cow if you want to
treat that cow for ten years and cows we
don't have insurance let's say a pig if
it has double knee replacement the
farmer doesn't have insurance for a
double knee replacement if he has
arthritis in his knee so they just eat
him goldfish if it's sick just flushed
him down the toilet
it's a flush treatment okay a dog if he
has a 2000 dollar treatment most of the
time he's going to heaven the next day
at 1 o'clock you know the exact moment
because you get the injection right so
in humans we have this problem there's
no law requiring a doctor to cure you
and there's a cure available you assume
because you're innocent that he wants to
cure you you assume because you're
innocent
that doctors want to cure you let's say
you have diabetes I can cure you in 2 to
14 days of diabetes the doctor makes 300
bucks from a office call the actually
the pharmacist will make more money from
from the medications right but if he can
treat you for 25 years rather than cure
you in 3 weeks
he makes $750,000 so it's not unethical
it's not unlawful for him to treat you
for 25 years and so which way is he
going to go $750,000 over 300 and that's
the problem in human medicine is
insurance is the worst possible thing
that can happen to human medicine
because it made the doctors figure out
how to get the insurance when they treat
you they ameliorate or dampen down
symptoms they do not cure the disease
every drug with the exception of
antibiotics which can kill let's say
have a strep throat there's an abaya
seem cure strep throat if you have
syphilis penicillin will cure syphilis
but it's always the infectious disease
with
antibiotic that we can cure there's a
250-thousand pharmaceuticals their
prescription drugs and the PDR the
physicians Desk Reference that they have
access to with the exception of
antibiotics which about 500 so two
hundred and forty nine thousand five
hundred our prescription drugs
non-antibiotic only treat symptoms
there's not a single pharmaceutical
other than antibiotic Secours of disease
they all treat symptoms when does the
doctor make the most money when you're
sick or when you're well you're sick
when did the pharmaceutical industry
make more money when you're sick I mean
you're well now the medical system has
legislated themselves into a protected
monopoly everybody but medical doctors
are quacks everybody knows that because
medical doctors tell you so they've
legislated themselves into a protected
monopoly they have no oversight by any
agency they self police and they have
unlimited money through government and
private insurance BAM you're dead now
I'm going to show you two things number
one I'm going to show you why you must
change what you're doing let me show you
how to do it that fair now hold your
questions and comments till the end this
is going to be totally different than
any health lecture you've ever seen or
heard
[Applause]
now how many of you guys and gals know
heard of a guy by the name of Benjamin
Rush anybody know who Benjamin Rush was
okay couple of guys in the back like
Hill Benjamin Rush was the first
military surgeon in the United States he
was charged washington's military
surgeon he was the first US Surgeon
General and he was a signer of the
Declaration of Independence pledging
like all of the other fifty-six his life
his fortune and his his personal good
name okay and this is part of a letter
he wrote to Benjamin Franklin and also
the other writers of the Constitution
cluding Thomas Jefferson unless we put
medical freedom into the Constitution
because the different factions of
medicine were fighting herbalist versus
chemical users and those using oriental
medicine and so forth they were fighting
amongst themselves and so he was
pleading for a a clause in the
Constitution that would equal right to
choose religion right to freedom of
speech right he wanted another one in
there unless we put medical freedom into
the Constitution the time will come in
medicine will organize itself into an
undercover dictatorship to restrict the
art of healing to one class of men and
deny equal privileges to others will
constitute the Bastille which is the
most horrible prison in France at the
time of medical science all such laws
are on American and despotic well of
course that didn't happen this clause
didn't get into the Constitution and now
his worst nightmares have come true 300
years later now we spend more money for
health care than all the other nations
are all combined there's 200 foreign
nations registered in the United Nations
of those 204 nations we spend more money
for health care than all the rest not
more than any nation more than all
nations and what do we get far we're
ranked 92nd and healthfulness in the
world
there's 91 other nations whose peoples
are healthier than us we're ranked 60th
and longevity there's 59 other nations
whose peoples live longer than us and
God forgive us we're ranked 41st when it
comes to live births and first month
survivability babies that doesn't even
count the abortion piece Time magazine
December 2008 cover article the sorry
state of American health despite
technological advances in medicine
Americans are less healthy than we used
to be and the next generation our kids
are gonna be worse off how many of you
have heard that that their kids are not
going to live as long as the animals
okay that's two thirds of you what
they're saying here is is statistically
three-quarters of you in this room will
be standing a gravesite bearing your
children unless we change what we're
doing petitions are the doctor's
petitions the government aren't going to
change anything that's not going to
change anything there's only one way to
change the system and that is to not use
it cut off their cash flow suddenly now
they become real humble but you have to
make that decision well it takes a
responsibility in your part and I'm here
to teach you the things you can do for
yourself to avoid using them
unnecessarily that makes sense so that's
where we're going just so you don't
think I made that up in ranking of a
newborn deaths
again we're 41st in the world when it
comes to live births and first month
survivability babies and they say it's a
shame it's not a shame it's a absolute
crime and most OBG when Oh most OBGYNs
and most pediatricians should go to jail
for it
[Applause]
I don't know if you've ever heard of the
scientific journal called food chemistry
it looks at the nutritional value of
food grown here in the United States and
food import of the United States also
looks for pollution so I'm kind of
familiar with that one and in the April
issue of this year April 2012 there was
a big article in there that looked at
eight very well-known trusted names and
baby foods Gerber's Similac Enfamil
these kind of things and what they said
was that commercially available baby
foods contain less than 20% of the
recommended levels of many vitamins and
minerals and less than 20% this is why
we have autism and a DD and ADHD it has
nothing to do with vaccinations nothing
I've looked at the batch numbers and
ingredients and manufacturers they send
the same batch numbers in the same
ingredients and it's all over the world
and 95% of all autism occurs here in the
United States so it can't be the
vaccinations because it is used
everywhere else so what is it is
malnutrition of the brain you cannot
make a good brain on Fruity Pebbles and
apple juice most kids who have autism
and ATD and ADHD are normal until they
go from formula to solid food what's
their solid food pop-tarts and Welch's
grape juice no Sunny Delight and a goes
with syrup all carbohydrates
carbohydrates carbohydrates there's no
fans there's no proteins there's no
vitamins or minerals and you get what
you get you can't make a brain on
carbohydrates only so here's your
pediatrician should go to jail this is
from May of this year cover article
Newsweek magazine and the first reaction
of most people is to have a little
giggle because he's a cute little fat
kid year old he's clutching his
supersize bag of french fries but this
is probably the scariest slide you're
going to see tonight because this is one
of the reasons why your kids will not
live as long as you they're predicting
already that this kid here year old when
you when I grow up I'm going to weigh
300 pounds
raise your hand if you know we're the
number one obese nation in the world
anybody know that yeah well good i
don'ts kind of interesting line there
and those people don't know we're the
number 100 beast nation their world the
only thing that we're number one and in
the health industry is obesity now what
does that tell you about the medical
systems and the government's knowledge
about obesity they know nothing
otherwise we'd be number 204 we should
be the slimmest trim as fit as people on
earth but they know nothing about the
thing that makes us the sickest people
on earth obesity and we'll talk about
that in a minute the little piece here
came out the 19th of September just
about a month ago in 2010 36% of
Americans are obese 2030 they're
projecting the 50% will be obese now
what that tells you is they know nothing
because if they knew something and they
could predict what's going to happen in
20 years they should say well it's 36%
now but in 20 years we'll be 20 percent
another 20 years will be 5% but instead
of going up which means they have no
earthly idea how to stop it
some states like Mississippi the most
obese nation are excuse me in the state
in America the most obese right now
they're going to be sixty six point
seven percent almost 67 percent obesity
two thirds obesity is what they're
projecting for same thing for Maryland
or Delaware I guess as Delaware's 64.7%
almost 65 percent and then you're
looking at South Carolina sixty-three
percent this young fella died at 21
years of age of Crohn's disease and a
certain type of liver disease called a
primary scrolling cholangitis which is a
simple nutritional deficiencies
how many verda Crohn's disease okay
Crohn's disease is a simple problem very
simple problem they say it's an
autoimmune thing and he fought valiantly
for 11 years then he died all he did was
give him prednisone and cortisone and
you know telling me he you know give up
lettuce and was stupid things like that
right and he died at 21 years of age of
complications of Crohn's disease and
liver disease all he had to do was go on
a gluten-free diet we'll talk
that in a minute on a gluten-free diet
take the 90 essential nutrients and he'd
live to be a hundred and twenty-one but
when it comes to these things
doctors are either very stupid are
they're criminals because if they know
the answer and they choose to treat him
rather than cheer him they should have
cured him when he's ten years old and
three to six months but if they're
ignorant that means they don't know what
to do if they know what to do and they
choose to treat him for a long period of
time for the money that means they're
criminals right and so I'll give him the
benefit out and just say they're stupid
ignorant people this came out October
11th this is month stroke rates increase
among showing our patients is happening
in younger and younger and younger
people now that are getting stroke and
there's many many reasons for that but
the basic reason is there's two types of
stroke eighty-five percent of all
strokes are caused by blood clots in the
brain thrombotic stroke this is caused
by simple deficiency the omega-3
essential fatty acids or a ratio plum
between omega-3 sixes and nines now
showed pros to you I actually sued the
FDA over this and prevailed in federal
court and I'll show you what to do to
prevent strokes very simply AARP their
monthly bulletin American Association of
Retired people I'm glad to see so many
young people in here because we got to
start young right we can't wait till
people my doctor says I have three
seconds to live can you save me with
behind
you'd be amazed at how many people I get
like that oh I heard you're taped 20
years ago I didn't do anything and now I
got two seconds to live can you help me
okay so the AAR people in March of this
year the worst place to be in America
when you're sick is an American Hospital
I took two pieces out of the body of the
article and one of which is the number
of American patients who die each year
from American Hospital errors is equal
to four jumbo jets crashing each week
that's about 1,200 to 1,500 people per
week how many of you would fly
commercial airlines if you knew they
killed 1200 1500 passengers every week
nobody would fly I must see my doctor I
must see my doctor and then also in the
same issue each u.s. surgeon each u.s.
surgeon operates in the wrong person
wrong body part is often his forty times
a week well that brought sounds to the
room that's because they're usually
intoxicated on alcohol street drugs or
prescription drugs and that comes from a
six year ago study by Lucian lepay who's
the head of the department of public
health at Harvard Medical School and he
went around and blindly took blood
samples from doctors he just showed up
and took blood samples from and he ran
him and fifty-two percent are
intoxicated during their working day on
something that's why they make so many
mistakes it's published stuff from
Harvard Medical School music magazine
cover article why is that guy terrified
well he's not even anesthetized though
surgeons are ready to stick him with
their scalpels that's because if they
even touch him with their scalpels
before he undergoes anesthesia they've
started their procedure if he dies
during the induction of anesthesia which
happens quite frequently because they
don't turn on the oxygen and because
they're drunk yeah and he dies let's say
during the induction of anesthesia they
can run off and play golf for four hours
and so get paid their $100,000
so they want to start the procedure
right now the one word that will save
your life in a hospital is a two letter
word that every two-year-old knows know
whatever they tell you you're gonna say
it respond by saying no now what does it
guy afraid of I mean this is a universal
fear posture right doesn't matter what
language you speak if you're doing this
you're afraid of something
no let's say you're in the hospital you
have fourth stage cancer it's gone to
the regional lymph nodes may be gone
from your coal into your lungs you're in
real trouble they said look we've given
you four rounds of chemotherapy nothing
seems to be working if we have this new
experimental drug coming out in a couple
of weeks and we want to try it on you
your response should be no because they
know that it's not going to work on you
ninety cent percent of the time
chemotherapy doesn't work for cancer
that's published in the Journal of
oncology about three years ago 97% of
the time chemotherapy is useless they
gotta give you something it'll shrink
the tumor a little bit but you still die
okay no so this experimental drug does
it me the same way it's gonna shrink the
tumor a little bit but you still die and
so what they're asking you to do is to
let them use you as a guinea pig to see
if just the injection the drug kills you
because they have to have a hundred
patients who will be injected with a
drug and they have to have less than
three die from the in drug itself before
they approve it so we're looking for the
village idiot to say okay see if I'm the
one you're gonna kill
so what is he afraid of well there are
seven physicians on the other facing
page and once you look at their body
language and their faces to see if
they're coming into him as good
Samaritans they remind me of the Walking
Dead series on TV the doctors are the
Walking Dead and the reason why they're
coming for him is he is the only one in
the hospitals money everybody else is a
Medicare patient they don't have any
money
they'll play hockey out there they'll
knock each other down because they want
to be the one to get to him to get the
money these are not uncommon things
usually Reader's Digest is a very chummy
magazine was really great stories you
know the dog drags a kid out of the fire
in the house and the two-year-old calls
911 say it's grandma from a heart attack
but look at this cover article in 2007
June 2007 fatal Hospital mistakes how
common is that well in 1999 I had made
one of my I don't know 436 CDs I have
out there and I used I have to admit I
used the title of a movie
how many heard of the Ray Milland movie
some year old enough remember that old
Ray Milland movie dial M for murder that
ulema is a great movie and then it was
remade here about ten years ago or 15
years ago with Michael Douglas called
the perfect murder the same storyline
just new technology and stuff to make it
modern but it was same storyline all I
did was change it by one letter instead
of saying dial M for murder I sat down
MD for murder doctors didn't like that
they just like went crazy and been in in
this CD
in the cd-i I read this stuff from this
newspaper article each year in America
VA medical doctors make 3,000 mistakes
which which cost the patient there a
limb or an eye or to stay in the
hospital for another six months because
of infections or whatever and all those
3,000 mistakes that are inflicted on VA
patients every year by VA doctors the VA
doctors kill 700 veterans that have
scaped death at the hands of the enemy
so they come home to be treated by our
doctors our doctors kill them they come
home to be treated by our doctors of a
hospital and each year the VA doctors
kill 700 of our veterans have went out
there to protect us and the doctors get
a walk they never go to jail because
they have a protected monopoly they can
kill maim rape and and burned with
impunity and they're untouchable this
came out there's a full page story in
the USA Today in February 2007 I had to
chop it up a little bit to get on those
eight-and-a-half by eleven look at that
look at the title here patient protect
thy self now the data that I'm gonna
share with you came from the journal the
American Medical Association very very
well-respected journal whether you agree
with them or not they are very well
respected and then the Center for
Disease Control which is a federal
agency in Atlanta Georgia the looks at
this stuff and what the article said was
each year in America each year in
America medical doctors kill injured in
fact 15 mil that our customers our
workplace they get a walk they don't get
an OSHA ticket each year in American
medical doctors kill injured in fact 15
million of their customers in the
workplace 5.8 million in hospitals and
9.2 million private office of clinics
how many of you would fly commercial
airlines if you knew that they killed
injured infected 15 million passengers
every year nobody would fly this is one
of my favorites
each year America medical doctors
inflict two million infections on
hospital patients all those 2 million
infections 90,000 die they kill 90
thousand people each year just from
infections that they inflict on the
patient now
how could that happen well that's
because they were the same white coat
the same pantyhose the same trousers the
same shoes from room to room to room
dragging Peapod puss snot gunk viruses
bacteria everything you can think of by
contrast in a pig barn by federal law
you're required to disinfect your boots
when you go from one pig pen to the neck
because you want to be dragging swine
flu with you we treat pigs better than
we do people we treat pigs in a barn
than we do people in a hospital now I
want you think about this if Iran were
to ship over one of their
intercontinental ballistic missiles
which they're always testing with a WMD
a weapon of mass destruction there was a
biological weapon a bio weapon which
viruses and bacteria would kill 90,000
people let's say they lob that thing
right into Minneapolis and killed 90,000
people in a couple of weeks or a month
what we do what we do well we declare
war we just go over there and flatten
that country in the rubble kill a lot of
people you know well please say you're
sorry no probably not we sue them and
say we we want some retribution we want
a million dollars per person for every
one you kill probably not we declare war
we go kill them all well here you have
doctors that kill 90,000 every year just
simply because they don't wash their
hands after they go potty yum yum yummy
now how can I say that well this came
out in August but almost exactly two
months ago tomorrow will be two months
ago one bacteria causes 30,000 deaths in
hospitals every year that's one third of
the 90,000 right there's one bacterial
seed if it's Clostridium differentials
which is only found in human poop say
human poop bacteria human feces bacteria
it comes only from doctors and nurses
not washing their hands patient a
patient a patient to show you how
concerned they are about it doctors in
1993 there were eighty-five thousand
seven hundred cases of c diff infections
in hospitals reported and by 2010 went
up four hundred to three hundred and
forty six thousand eight hundred he's
getting better or worse well the numbers
worked it's getting worse so when do you
say is nothing enough when do you get
pissed off enough to say enough is
enough we're not gonna use you guys
anymore don't you think remember when
that Toyota there was six thousand six
was it sixty people got killed
sixty people got killed in was four
years or five years from Twyla's
accelerator problem twelve twelve people
a year I mean it was a big hoo-ha
oh I mean everybody suing for billions
of dollars front-page stories it was a
mess here we have one trade in their
workplace they killed ninety thousand
from infections every year because they
don't wash their hands after they go
potty
nobody cares that's because they haven't
protected monopolies are you beginning
to get a picture here now there's
another one of my favorites because I've
got some very famous examples to show
you hospital care fatal for some
patients kind of you know vanilla
results of Medicare study alarming well
that's alarming well the study was done
by the US Department of Health and Human
Services Office of Inspector General
Office of Inspector General that's the
auditor for Medicare well they said was
each month an American medical doctors
kill fifteen thousand Medicare
with non invasive procedures each month
medical doctors kill 15,000 medication
Medicare patients from non-invasive
procedures how many of you fly
commercial airlines if you know they
killed 15,000 seniors a month especially
if you receive I ain't going on that
plane man I'm driving well it's because
of famous people that they've killed who
are seniors about Andy Rooney anybody
remember Andy Rooney from 60 minutes
sunday afternoon it's kind of a TV show
well he retired almost exactly a year
going on in October of last year he
retired in 92 years old and he knows why
we're gonna run his world cruise and so
they decided they were gonna go in for a
physical in case they need to take some
medication with him they didn't want to
be out in the ocean for six months and
have to go to some doctor in a foreign
country that they didn't know and all
that kind of stuff and so the doctor for
Andy Rooney he's kind of leafing through
his medical records and he said Andy
you're 92 years old here and I can't
find where you've ever had a colonoscope
exam I mean there could be cancer
lurking around in there and of course he
had no symptoms no bleeding in his bowel
movements no pain no weight loss he's
happy as a clam waiting to go on to his
cruise what he should have said was no
but instead what he said was okay
because he didn't want to offend the
doctor in white coat no stethoscope so
the doctors six a garden hose up his
rump puncture his intestine three days
later he's dead from paradise a belly
infection nothing wrong with a guy in a
good doctor kills him no they didn't
name the doctor they didn't name the
hospital because if that in the hospital
and the doctor's name went out I mean my
god it wouldn't interrupt their cash
flow everybody canceled it would be a
mess right so they're not going to name
those guys know what makes this really
bad is in here the cause of death is
listed you go online and look at Andy
Rooney obituary and you'll find him they
always say mr. Rooney died of
complications of a minor medical
procedure
well one cut wasn't minor for him it
killed him
doctor gets a walk Hospital gets a walk
honey you heard a dick Clark you know
American Bandstand okay
he went in for an outpatient procedure
he was supposed to be having the
procedure 11 done by 11:30 out in the
golf course by one o'clock that's what
he was told
now what he was gonna have was one of
those little roto-rooter things I was
prostate gland cuz he had to stand from
the table for you know two or three
minutes where you get a urine stream
going so instead of coming to me and
getting it fixed with nutrition it's a
simple nutritional problem instead of
getting a fix of nutrition he opts for
the scientific thing let's do surgery
and row to root it out starts at 11
o'clock as scheduled 11:30 is dead he
died of a coronary thrombosis that
happens to 30,000 men each year within
an hour after the procedure
now there's another 200,000 each year
that have a stroke or a coronary
thrombosis but they don't die 30,000 of
them die every year from that procedure
I'll show you that fact in a minute now
to remember a guy by the name of Neil
anybody remember Neil I'll give you one
more piece of the name how about Neil
Armstrong how do you remember Neil
Armstrong our top astronaut right the
first guy to step foot on the moon he
saved single-handedly he saved two NASA
missions saved the spacecraft saved two
crews it was a mess that he saved NASA
from a terrible disaster two times so
he's eight years old he goes in for his
physical they kneel you're eight years
old we've never seen a specimen like his
82 years old you're as fit as can be
that NASA program must be really great
but we did find one little thing we're
concerned about you have a blocked
artery got a 30% blockage in a coronary
artery now it's not dangerous now you
don't even have symptoms no I don't have
any chest pain or anything no angina
okay you're not breath no he said I can
run 20 miles every day no problem okay
well you're fit now and what we're
proposing is we don't wait for five
years until the 70% blocked or 85
percent block we don't wait until you
have a heart attack I mean all night you
died in the
the hospital you're fit now and all we
want to do is go in there and put a
stent in there do a bypass and you'll
never have to worry about a heart attack
I mean we were lucky we found it early
yes sir
good naval air man let's go for it well
would it Neal died from he didn't have a
heart attack he died from complications
resulting from cardiovascular procedures
see the story was not all the wonderful
things as Neil Armstrong did in his life
that was not the story the headline
should have been doctors kill top
astronaut but since they have a
protective monopoly they killed him and
they're hiding you don't know who the
doctor was that killed him but if there
had been a successful thing that he had
this news conference and all the white
coats and stethoscope oh yeah I was a
very difficult thing and we saved the
astronaut and how wonderful my name is
doctor so here's my 800 number you can
call me for appointments and it would
been big hoo-ha right
but since they killed him no he'll let
you know who they are are you beginning
to get a picture here so they can kill
an Andy Rooney a Dick Clark and Neil
Armstrong and another couple of hundred
thousand people each year who are
nameless because they're not famous
Michael Jackson there's another one
stupid doctor Murray probably snortin
half of Michaels drugs
no Michael just happen to pick one of
the dumbest most careless doctors on
earth 100 hurt a cholesterol raise your
hand
you know the substance cholesterol okay
good now I'm here to tell you this
there's not a single disease that's
caused by elevated blood cholesterol
there's not a single disease is caused
by elevated blood cholesterol elevated
blood cholesterol is a red warning light
how do you ever seen the red warning
light in the dashboard of a car whether
it turns on or not you know there's a
red warning light right there's
something's going on with the engine can
you name me anything that that the any
mechanical or chemical or electrical
thing that the red warning light
inflicts upon your vehicle no the red
warning light as the name implies it
warns you that something bad is going on
you need to add more coolant you need to
add more oil you may have blown a head
gasket you don't want to drive it you
want to get towed in so you get the
engine fixed that's what the red warning
line is warning you right well elevated
blood cholesterol is a warning
I wrote that up in 1971 it was published
it was like translated into six
languages a Danish pathology journal
ACTU pathologic and was it was a big
thing and I compared clogged arteries in
vegans versus meat-eaters vegans of
course I think we're all not young
enough to know the vegans are people who
are vegetarians who eat nothing but
grains vessels fruits and nuts no animal
products and they believe that's a
healthy thing but I don't believe it's
healthy this is a political statement
because they say okay well one cow eats
as much food as 50 people if we're all
eating stuff like cows and get the cow
out of the cycle we can feed 50 more
people right I mean that's how vegans
think well a cow has four stomachs
you can't process grass the same way
account of us you got fifty thousand
little helpers in there
I mean fifty thousand individual
organism and fifty thousand different
species of individual organs you've got
billions and billions and billions of
little organism there that do things
that you don't have the capacity to do
so you can't live on pasture grass like
a cow so being a vegan is a political
statement rather than a nutritional
statement right
so what he did when you when you do
twenty thousand-plus autopsy and all
these different species and three
thousand humans 10 million slides 10
million chemistry's you can write a lot
of articles which I did write one of
which was comparing the amount of
clogging of the coronary arteries and
vegans versus meters guess who had the
worst clogged arteries vegans because of
poorly stored grains the oils and the
grains oxidize and turn into trans fatty
acids free radicals which inflame the
arteries and cause them to clog another
thing that happens with vegans they
stir-fry organic vegetables and extra
extra extra extra extra virgin virgin
virgin virgin olive oil turns into trans
fatty acid in flames your arteries and
clogs your arteries somebody lives on
you know the meat and potatoes guy it's
all he's not burning the meat if he's
eating his meat raw you know or medium
or medium rare and having some baked
potatoes he won't get clogged arteries
because there's no trans fatty acids any
of that you're getting a picture here so
just because somebody says something's
good when you have to look at it and see
if it really is well again
cholesterol is not bad if you have
elevated blood cluster on the normal
cholesterol for human beings a normal
range is 220 to 270 222 to 70 is in the
normal range and if you have a blood
cholesterol without medication that's
below 200 you have gluten intolerance
because you can't absorb cholesterol
I've seen people with a cholesterol at
60 in their doctor man you you can eat
10 eggs a day and not worry about it
yeah you got cholesterol 90 a man you're
lucky no no you're dying because you
have a gluten intolerance you can't
absorb cholesterol which is very big
complicated molecule okay so FDA has new
safety information to Stanton drugs
cholesterol or in drugs February 2012
federal health officials are adding new
safety warnings about the risk of statin
drugs for memory loss Alzheimer disease
and elevated blood sugar if you take
statin drugs lower your cholesterol for
ten years and at the same time you're on
a cholesterol restricted diet you're
gonna increase your risk of Alton
disease by 100
in other words you're going to get a
house and Rosie's it predictable as
gravity I'll tell you why in a minute
also if you're on statin drugs law Rico
and you have a cholesterol restricted
diet for ten years increase your risk of
type 2 diabetes by 50%
what causes elevated blood closures
glycerides is it's a red warning light
for diabetes it's a red warning light
for low thyroid it's a red warning light
for deficiencies of six different
minerals it in itself causes nothing I
said that 1971 everybody Lyons everybody
there's 25 doctors I used to hang around
with and of course they just put their
arms around said a wallet can mean you
know you must be sniffin glue everybody
knows it's though it's the cholesterol
man well they all took their standard
drugs and guess what
they're all dead I'm alive
god is good
okay science news is kind of a a summary
Journal for doctors they they look at
thousands of scientific articles written
every month and they summarize them so
doctors can read the summaries which
usually are a half a page and they like
something they can send somebody to get
the entire article they don't to read
thousands of articles this came out in
June of this year good cholesterol not
so beneficial high higher HDL high
density lipoprotein the good cholesterol
don't reduce heart attacks I said that
1971 everybody laughed at me as
published you go back and read it
okay and so it's nice to be redeemed a
little bit right I'm gonna go to each of
their graves and put one of these on
their hood okay now there's not a single
medical screening test that prevents a
disease and I saw on TV the other night
when the American Cancer Society so
talking about get your screens to
prevent cancer there's not a single
screening test medical screening test
prevents a disease now it might catch it
earlier we can get into the treatment
system which can be a bad or good thing
right so this is the globin mail which
is the USA Today equivalent in Canada
it's a national newspaper I just like
this title along with that picture here
screening is not prevention now how many
of you ladies have heard of mammograms
raise your hand if you don't raise your
hand you're probably lying we Haven men
of heard of mammograms right and that's
one of the great screens that doctors
like to use OBGYNs your primary care
physician will send you in for a
mammogram every year once you're 40
years of age well you know women I don't
know 10 15 20 years ago when these
things were really being pushed they
said what about all that radiation I
don't you know I'm trying to stay away
from radiation I'm protesting against
nuclear power plants want me to put my
breasts in that machine
oh it's insignificant radiation how many
women have heard that yeah well it just
came out about three weeks ago they said
one mammogram one mammogram gives you
the amount of radiation of 500 chest
x-rays Wow sorry
a little mistake it was a decimal point
problem
[Laughter]
one mammogram one cat scan one MRI gives
you the equivalent radiation 500 chest
x-rays if you have one mammogram ladies
a year for five years increases your
risk of breast cancer by 20% and if
you're taking HRT if you're taking you
know estrogen along with that oh you're
up to 60% increase in risk of breast
cancer if you're if you're eating your
meat cooked well done at the same time
it increases your risk of breast cancer
by 462 percent I'll actually show you
that that experiment that experiment was
done there was a 20-year study on the
Nurses Health Study by the University of
South Carolina on 90,000 nurses over 20
years increases your risk of breast
cancer by 462 percent now to see does
Susan G Komen tell you that no so next
time your doctor says look it's time for
you I looking in here you're beyond your
year you need to go get a mammogram you
should say well I don't think I want to
do I'm concerned about the safety and
the doctors say well I insist because
I'm one responsible for your health I
don't want you to get breast cancer now
what he's really saying is I don't want
to give up my $400 I get kicked back
from the radiology laboratory because
radiology is one of the things that
doctors get kickbacks on to get an
ultrasound they get 10 bucks a mammogram
it's 400 bucks they're happy about those
things right now so what you're gonna
say ladies is this look I'm concerned
about safety if you can convince me to
say if I'll do the mammogram and here's
what I want you to do why don't you do
is put your testicles in the machine
and I want you to let me be the one to
crank down on that plate until you've
grown a little bit God then I want to be
the one to yell to the guy standing
behind the two inches of lead and say
hit it Frank if you'll let me do those
three things
I'll get the mammogram and you know what
that doctors gonna say no you can do
your own self-examination 10 o'clock in
the morning on the 15th of every month
even if you're 10 years into menopause
and keep a log and map out your breasts
or all the little bumps and lumps or
you've had all your life you know what
kind of thing and but suddenly now this
little pea-sized knot that's been there
forever is a little tender not never
used to be tender go get a high
definition ultrasound will actually give
you more information than a mammogram
there's no radiation now you guys don't
get off easy a federal panel now is
destroying PSA prostate screening why
PSA risk might not be worth and this is
where that 30,000 number came from how
de been fair after this surgery oops
houston we have a problem Time magazine
health and science section June 4th 2012
skipped the PSA screen experts say PSA
blood test for prostate cancer don't
save lives now and Warren Buffett was
diagnosed with prostate cancer in April
of this year he chose aggressive
treatment surgery radiation chemotherapy
has anybody seen or heard of him in the
last 6 months
is he dead in the freezer waiting for
the stock market to go right before they
reveal his death I mean is he off
recovering in some island someplace so
he's in a coma is he in Hospice I mean
we don't have any we don't know what's
going on right wait wait
this is his story but the most important
piece of the story when this was written
up was this paragraph here Richard a
blonde the scientists who discovered the
PSA test calls the testings widespread
use a public health disaster because it
gives a 98% false positive
gives a doctor's permission to kill you
prostate cancer does not kill anybody if
you have prostate cancer you die it's
always from the treatment it never goes
to your liver your lungs your brain
never kills you it goes regionally it'll
go into your pelvic bones here and
lumbar vertebrae in your leg bones but
that's it probably 90% of all men who
die over the age 85 have prostate cancer
is usually the size of the head of a pin
never left the prostate gland but the
PSA test is like a hundred instead of
below five like it's supposed to be oh
my god oh oh oh you got to get treatment
here hmm you're dead now doctors have
become pre grave robbers they got a
couple more of these then you'll
understand where doctors are coming from
then I'll tell you what to do fart okay
I got a few more to show you a couple
more categories here Medicare costs for
hospice is up 70% every year 70% 70% 70%
how much does it cost to stick your
finger on somebody's trying to already
see if they're dead there need a lot of
technology there right and so why would
hospice co-op 70% every year well here's
why doctors become pre grave robbers
let's here in Hospice let's his grandma
Daisy
grandma Daisy's in the hospice and she's
got stage 4 colon cancers gone to her
brain she's in a coma she being fed IV
and the doctor calls for conference the
immediate family there at the hospice
and they're all in their tears coming
down looking at Grandma Daisy there
she's kind of gonzo she's in a coma
because cancer is gone from her colon
her brain the doctor saying look she we
can pull the blo plug she'll be dead in
three days but I recommend we kind of do
what we can to keep her going here I
want you to sign a paper allowing us to
resuscitate her if she has cardiac
arrest because there's this new drug
coming along and it might just help her
of course
the instinct is a wonder grasp onto that
last straw right yeah well let's go for
it you know we got insurance
you'll pay for it and so everybody
especially as you and verily it's the
biggest guy in the family you know the
grandson who's 7 foot tall tied in you
know weighs 300 pounds and
can kill you with a look right and he
looks at the doctor and says whatever
grandma Daisy needs she gets right oh
yes sir
gram Oh Daisy was a she ironed our
underwear she made all our food from
scratch nothing ever canned or frozen
she was the best
whatever grandma Daisy needs she gets
and as he's walking out the door
whatever grandma do don't forget she
gets the best oh yes sir well as soon as
everybody signs a paper and they've left
the room
this doctor this hospice doctors on the
internet calling all his golf buddies I
checked out grandma Daisy here and she's
got three hundred thousand dollars left
in all her accounts between Medicare or
private insurance and everything and her
supplements
she had three hundred thousand dollars
there there in a heartbeat okay to give
her a hysterectomy double mastectomy
they'll do a double hip replacement
double knee replacement cataract
surgeries if she has one tooth they'll
yank that doing upper and lower dentures
and then they put implants in her middle
ear because she was deaf and then they
pulled up lexico when they call him
grandma Daisy had a turn for the worse
and she died but only after they get the
money so what I want you to do is have a
hospice at home Medicare will pay for
hospice at home everybody comes in and
needs to come there and do it was
necessary to give her a better thing but
you have some control here if you let
her I have her dog in her bed with her
you let the grandkids sleep with her if
they want she can have a gallon of ice
cream every night if she wants
you can't give grandma Daisy ice cream
in a hospice she's dying you can't let
the grandkids come if she's in intensive
care you can't let grandkids come in to
give grandma Daisy a hug do you see the
difference here why do you want the
people you love dying by themselves well
the nurses are all chasing the doctors
around the library at night
after all that's where the plush chairs
all right just you know that I'm not
making this stuff up
doctor repeat surgery probe gives up
license now this guy did he had ten
times the number of repeat surgeries on
people than any other doctor in the
state of Oregon and it was only because
he had 40 lawsuits against him that the
that the organization did something
about it this came out in September 7th
of this year he goes healthcare weights
750 billion dollar three quarters of a
trillion dollars that's three quarters
with Chilean trillion dollars every year
the medical system waste three quarters
of a trillion dollars a year that's your
tax money now what was the waste far
unneeded care in hospice I never say
anything I can't back up this is gonna
make you feel warm and fuzzy each of you
owes the Chinese government five hundred
thirty four thousand dollars
which total of seven is 62 trillion now
why is that that's because over the last
30 years each one of your elected
officials in Washington regardless of
party independents libertarians
Democrats Republicans they all did it
what they did was they took all your
money from your Social Security funds
your Medicare your Medicaid funds and
gave it over to the highway departments
what you see all this highway work going
on here
that's your Social Security money that's
your Social Security money okay and and
this was so they could come back and say
I brought home the bacon last year I got
a hundred new jobs in this district and
I want you to reelect me oh you have a
job well when the first when the first
baby boomers came along 80 million I'm
the first wave about four years ago came
along okay we're here for our so sturdy
everybody's looking each other in
Washington we don't have any money so
well you got to wait six months thanks
you're gonna wait another six months and
so now I think you got to be 70 before
he gets your first payment and Social
Security used to be 65 right got to keep
waiting and waiting and waiting
that's why cuz there's no money there so
they run to the Chinese we need money
okay we'll give you the 62 trillion
dollars and once some security here so
what security did they have to give for
62 trillion dollars it wasn't a
signature in their name
what it was was all the weekly revenues
from federal lands oil leases we're
talking about timber permits raising
permits all of the tolls from the
federal toll roads weekly bypasses all
the American banks and go straight to
China not even keeping up with the
interest because this is a year old is
now 70 trillion this is outside that
sixteen trillion that's you know we're
behind in our budget this year we're
behind in her budget sixteen trillion
that doesn't count
I knew that would make you feel warm and
fuzzy now doctors are always at the
bottom of it this came out in 1997 a
1997 study by the Health Insurance
Association American found the 75% of
insurance fraud which is a federal crime
is committed by providers which is a
code word for doctors you do that you go
to jail doctors don't they get a walk
and you do have to change your diet now
we're changing subjects a little bit
here you have to change your diet part
of responsibility there's 20 of these
billboards around the Beltway around
Chicago say why on earth were they -
they had that's because 75 years ago the
average age of diagnosis of colon cancer
was 61 now it's 38 and so this billboard
is directed to eight-year-olds he talked
to a an 8 year old about grandma Daisy
dying of colon cancer well she was 82
years old I'm only 8 that's a million
years from now I'm not worried about
colon cancer and so this is directive
eight-year-old a what mama what's what's
butt cancer well when I was a kid 31 oh
when I was a kid 73 years ago when I was
a kid 73 years ago I had processed meats
with nitrates in it once a year that was
ham on Easterns now kids have processed
meats of nitrates into 15 times a day
they have bacon and eggs I get ham and
eggs you get sausage and eggs they get
the all meat breakfast with 14 different
types of sausages and bacon and ham and
pastrami and pepperoni and jerky and
then they get the bacon bits in their
salads you have bacon burgers and
there's in their little Lunchables
there's these little rods made from
pepperoni you know they're getting all
this nitrates and nitrates and then
there's fried foods you got to give up
fried foods this guy's been dead for 35
years he's still killing people
now you can eat safely at these places
you can eat save let McDonald's you need
safely at KFC but you got to be very
restricted on what you pick in KFC you
can only eat the Korf see Kentucky
roasted chicken and there's salad bar
that's it nothing else than there is
safe
same way with McDonald's when I go to
McDonald and I do that two or three
times a week because I'm on the road I
only eat there
Angus burgers I get the Swiss mushroom
one no mayonnaise no bun I have mad
lettuce pickles tomatoes and so I'm
having a little piece of meat and I'm
having a little salad but no dressing or
anything on it I could do get there
mild salsa cheddar little peg and put
the mild salsa on there and then I'll
don't drink their wild berry smoothies
and I will have their parfaits which is
a little yogurt that has blueberries and
strawberries in it that's the only three
things I'll eat at McDonald's but it's
very sad but going to McDonald's as
often as I do I always see grandmothers
and grandfathers you know they're like
in their 70s and 80s here's a little kid
in a highchair two three years old and
he's gonna smash and potatoes and doing
the things that little kids doing high
chairs and here's grandma with the
chicken McNuggets and she's always
ripping the skin off the chicken
McNuggets a little Frankie watch grandma
goody-goody no no no no good for you
here honey all these little skins of the
chicken McNuggets so when I do an
autopsy on a kid 12 years old who dies
leukemia I don't put cause of death as
leukemia well you know you have to have
a cause of death I always put grandma it
was crammed all grandma was the one that
gave him permission to eat the fried
foods he gave me leukemia
now how many you have a dog anybody in
here have a dog okay good
you haven't eaten him yet
now we've spent a hundred billion
dollars over the last 60 years on dog
food we've done research on dog food for
100 billion dollars over the last six
years what do we get for that well with
triple the lifespan of dogs six years
ago an old dog was eight years old today
oh the old dogs 25 also we've eliminated
900 different diseases and dogs that
still plague humans and all they want
all the dog food industry wants is the
next time you get your next dog you'll
use that same befall that dog who is
really good and you know a little lucky
here lived to be 25 years old and so I'm
gonna get that same dog food so that's
why they spent the hundred billion
dollars to make sure you would continue
to use their branded dog food No
couple of questions here they make dog
food for toy dogs under 10 pounds of
body weight if you've ever bought dog
for you know this they have dog food for
toy dogs under 20 pounds of body weight
they have dog food for medium-sized dogs
35 to 50 pounds they have dog food for
large reasons between 1500 pounds they
have dog food for giant breeds over a
hundred pounds that's so every mouthful
is perfect dosage wise by contrast when
you look at where there's nutritional
supplements or if it's a cough medicine
or prescription drugs there's the age is
12 this is for somebody under age 12
this for somebody over age 12 you know
animals are reached well how many read
those so yeah it's on the
over-the-counter stuff yeah it's
everything well I know a little kids at
12 years old there's 300 pounds I know
eighty year old people who are 70 pounds
so you can't go by age you got to go by
weight and that's why we're more
successful in the ambulance because we
go by weight so here comes the ultimate
question there's two ultimate questions
if you were to ask your veterinarian hey
can I get my dog the table scraps and
leftover is preferentially to dog food I
mean it's cost me a buck fifty a day to
feed this you know eighty pound dog and
my paycheck I cut in half here and I
really want to cut back and can I get my
dog table scraps and the veterinary
horrified what we spend a hundred
billion dollars perfecting dog food
eliminate nine hundred diseases a triple
the lifespan of your dog and you want to
feed them table scraps I'm a
veterinarian be mortified
no no no no can't do it so here comes
the ultimate question the ultimate
question how come you eat and you feed
your kids your grandkids food you know
what kill the dog
you eat you feed your kids grand grand
kids food that you know will kill a dog
so we came up with a 90 for life program
in youngevity it's called 90 for life
for two reasons number one is the 90th
centers and 60 mineral 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids 3 essential fatty
acids and what it means for life is for
a healthy life but it also means for
life for the length of your life how
many years do you need to take oxygen
all your life how many years you need
drink water all your life how many years
you need all 90 essential nutrients see
these are not the optional nutrients
these this is not the wax on the car
these are the things that drive the
engine there's another look at those 90
essential nutrients they're called
essential nutrients ladies and gentlemen
because we cannot manufacture there must
consume them every day there is food or
supplements number two if we if we don't
have them you get horrible diseases
which they will all be fatal over some
period of time every one of these you
know calcium deficiency caused 147
different diseases calcium deficiency
alone causes a one hundred and forty
seven different diseases I want you to
think about that why would the medical
profession want you to get all the
calcium you need there are people who
specialize in calcium deficiency disease
and they make millions of dollars every
year treating your calcium deficiency of
a surgery well what's in it for them if
they tell you what to do for your
nutrients you can overdose taking
vitamins in middle don't you dare take
them
oh my doctor says I can't take those
okay I can overdose they kill 1.5
million people a year from
pharmaceutical decimal point problems
from pharmaceutical decimal point
problems they kill 1.5 million people a
year
that's okay their FDA approved
okay we need 60 metal 16 bottom is 1200
mean OS is 3 essential fatty acids and
her food plants can take carbon dioxide
out of the air use the sun's energy
process known as photosynthesis to
manufacture long carbon chains with
which the plants make vitamins amino
acids fatty acids for themselves and
those societies that learn how to eat
these plants will get these things and
they live longer and healthier we need
60 minerals and you notice the number of
minerals is two thirds and then 90
essential nutrients so minerals are very
important well plants only need three
minerals we need sixty plants lead
magnesium to make the leaves green to
get energy from the Sun they also need
phosphorus potassium to drive growth
everything else they need to get from
the atmosphere nitrogen to make amino
acids and protein carbon to make every
other thing they need so if you're
eating a pretty good slice of
organically grown multigrain bread
organic baked by the pastor's wife in
church on Sunday after his best sermon
you're 57 short BAM you're dead but but
but he ate so well was all organic and
just baked with love now nutritional
minerals did not occur to uniformed
blank around the crust of the earth they
occur in veins like chocolate and
chocolate ice cream which remember that
piece is very important now how many
remember going to mom and dad's house or
some of you're too young for that you
might go to Grandma and Grandpa's house
and remember that they had a wood stove
anybody remember the wood stove days
yeah now what a grandma and grandpa do
with the wood ashes every morning do
they go in the recycling bin to save the
earth and went in the garden exactly
right went in the garden
well our wood ash is all the same no
remember the plant only needs three so
that tree might have only been in a vein
that had three minerals but it had six
eight 12 whatever was so all wood ashes
were not alike
okay but they put him in the garden and
plants benefited at a rate what Ash's
are not really ashes somebody gave him
that name thousands of years ago we kept
that name but they're really the
minerals that the tree sucked up out of
the
so there's plant minerals aka wood ashes
we throw them out in the garden the okra
and the tomatoes and the sweet potatoes
and the onions and all the all the peas
and beans and squash and corn and
everything you're growing out in the
garden suck all those minerals up eat
those plants you get your minerals in
that fashion right that's how the old
people used to get their minerals
through through the plant minerals aka
wood ash is going to the garden plants
uh come up eat the plants
well three o'clock in the afternoon
Monday September 4th 1882 three we know
at the exact moment three o'clock in the
afternoon Monday September 4th 1882
Thomas Edison pulled the switch in the
first commercial electric generating
plant within ten years everybody in the
city had converted from wood which is
inconvenient and messy for fuel to
electricity propane and natural gas and
here comes the ultimate question here
how many minerals are left over how many
ashes are left or would use electricity
for fuel zero and what did you replace
that source of nutritional meals with
nothing and that's why we're all screwed
up health-wise you gave up two thirds of
the nutrients by changing your source of
fuel and doctors say don't you take
vitamins knows you'll overdose and
they're not FDA approved
this is a cornfield from western
Nebraska won't you look at the universe
uniformity of those rows of corn look at
the uniformity there
every ear every leaf every stalk is
exactly the same same genetic background
is a miracle to behold I can guarantee a
couple of things just by looking at that
field I know there's at least three
minerals there because you'd have empty
patches there if they were missing any
one of the three magnesium phosphorus
potassium right so you know there's at
least that but can you without a $2500
analysis of each year corn can you tell
me which row has six minerals which row
has eight minerals which chrome has
twelve which row has 22 you can tell and
so in the animal industry we don't have
insurance to pay for silly things and so
we just put everything we know that
those animals need in their little
alfalfa pellets yeah we put the corn in
the soy beans all that stuff in alfalfa
pellets but we also put 60 mil 16 by 12
amino acids are essential fatty acids in
there and whatever nutrition is in the
alfalfa is value-added we don't depend
on it beard I saw that out here in the
auditorium are that gymnasium you know
is usually I'm sure they use it for
lunch room too it on that far wall
there's the for food plate used to be
the seventh food group period seven food
pyramid for a long time and the
government decided everything was going
bad because nobody could remember
everything on the southern food pyramid
they converted to four and leveled it
out into a plate you're supposed to eat
variety and eat put four different
colors on your food plate and everything
to be wonderful that's the most insane
approach to nutrition I've ever seen
somebody needs to go to jail here they
kill more people and all the terrorists
in the world combined every day now this
is a satellite photograph from a hundred
miles up of agricultural land in
Southern California over here is the
Pacific Ocean over here is um Arizona
down here is Mexico up here is the
Salton Sea which gives you some sense of
location there's a Salt Lake one-tenth
the size of the Great Salt Lake in Utah
but I want you to look at these mineral
vanes here look at those veins and
medals every color represents different
minerals different mixtures and minerals
different amounts of each one and so on
I remember pop I remember Popeye and
spinach he's supposed to get all your
iron from spinach everything well the
only place I can guarantee those give me
a lot of iron is over here because iron
in the soil turns it red
I can guarantee just by looking at this
photograph there's a lot more iron over
here than there is over here but am I
gonna spend to twenty five hundred
dollars on every kibble and bit in dog
food and every can of dog food and every
alfalfa pellets for a laboratory Ranma
cow tantalize it make sure it has
everything you need no don't do that
what they do is they put everything they
know that animal needs appropriate for
body weight and then whatever's in the
food is just value-added and if you're
expecting iron in your food down your
sweet potatoes your spinach and you're
getting your sweet potatoes finish over
here your s out of luck okay and so in
the animals they get a better deal
because we put everything in that food
now you're beginning to understand the
picture what about organic I've been
saying this since I did those studies in
the 1960s the National Institutes of
Health of a big multi-million dollar
study I did this is a meta study with
240 studies study sees no nutritional
edge in organics now people who grow
organics and people who sell organics
will lie to you there's more nutrition
in organic food that's a lie you need a
non-organic carrot could have 10 times
more minerals in it than a organic
carrot depends on what bein in the field
that grew in the only thinking guarantee
from organic is there's no sprays on it
which is not a bad thing that's a good
thing that's a plus no sprays you know
not your chemical load down that's a
good thing but they want you to also
believe that a guarantees nutrition it
does not so people who eat organic still
have to supplement this is what makes
you young Jody new unique this is a
compost pile
and this compost pile is made up of
plants or under the sea for thousands
and thousands and thousands of year this
is a 25-foot cap of marine limestone it
has this is a compost pile this is a
3000 foot elevation it goes down 2,000
feet into the ground in this plant
material so we were able to get it
certified organic every year for 35
years it has 77 minerals in it including
the 60 essential minerals thank you the
60 essential minerals in optimal amount
nobody else has this so this why we're
so successful with over 900 seasons
that's the miracle stuff I was 25
different ways to get that's the Russian
version okay okay no there's 25
different ways to do this but the most
which I say the most easy for people to
understand is the healthy start pack and
this little bottle is on top of here it
fits in a a kind of rectangular box this
has 245 nutrients in it which includes
130 vitamins minerals amino acids and
fatty acids including all 19 own
essential ones and then a bunch of the
others that are not yet considered the
essential will be but it's which I say
nobody is motivated to spend lots of
money to prove it because what are they
going to get for it
right and so it's not a commercial thing
and for the most part and certainly this
also has 115 super juices and how many
heard of the super juice like noni juice
goji juice mangosteen a Siberian Maqui
berry you know from Bolivia and so on
well Patagonia that's another place they
come from here right this is great stuff
has 245 nutrients plenty all 90
essential nutrients and optimum amount
and this is this is one healthy start
pack is designed for 100 pounds of human
flesh for a month so you give that one
pack to a 50 pound kit that's for two
months give to somebody who's 90 110
pounds for one month if you get to a 200
pound person this for two weeks because
by body weight that way we're more
accurate
right so we do everything in youngevity
by value because I'm a veterinarian and
a physician so I try to get as much as I
can the good stuff from the veterinary
industry and bring it over to people
that's why I say a treat you like a dog
would you get better and this is it this
is that chart just on the wall over
there I looked at that man that's
usually supposed to eat fruit and
vegetables and grains and protein and
everything's be fine that's why America
is sick
that's why all the jobs were shipped out
of America all the assembly jobs all the
manufacturing jobs are shipped out of
America because the high cost of medical
benefits for employees now how many how
many of you old enough to remember the
1962 presidential election anybody
remember that in here sir four people
are old enough okay him well there was a
three-way race between old Bush 41 Ross
Perot and Billy Clinton hmm the three
varies the only thing I can remember
from that campaign were they all four
three were running and they there were
only different by like three points
Billy Clinton won the presidency with 32
percent of the vote now in Europe in
England they would've had a runoff
between the top two guys but I'm been a
runoff between Billy Clinton old Bush
but Ross Perot had just about as many
votes as everybody else it was very
close kind of interesting race the only
thing I remember from the campaign was
Ross Perot was the biggest cartoon
character because huge years in Texas
accent all he showed was a Texas hat and
ear sticking out of it nose that was
Ross Perot his picture right great
cartoon stuff but hearing what he said
was if anybody signs NAFTA here this
giant sucking sound has all the jobs
leave America remember that Ted yeah
everybody said that guy's an idiot what
do you mean all those jobs really in
America were they gone well as soon as
Billy Clinton signed NAFTA like in his
first week as president that boy he
signed in doesn't be the greatest thing
he gave permission for all the publicly
traded corporations to leave the country
and take the jobs with him they started
building infrastructures in these
foreign countries soon as the
infrastructures built all the jobs
started going away that's because they
don't have
the need nor the requirement for health
care benefits in those foreign countries
now what is a publicly traded company
built for for who profit for who the
shareholders the owner of the company is
there any law moral or our legislative
law requiring a publicly traded company
to hire an employee no such law so they
took all the manufacturing jobs outside
of this country because nobody else has
requirements for health benefits
Southern America and doctors are
protected monopoly they just raise the
price of oh we got more we need more
money I mean the medical costs are going
up we need more money medical costs are
going up because you can't go to a
second person you can't go get a
competing bid for roof you go to three
or four or five or six different people
you can't you know compare quality with
money you can't do that with a doctor
because every doctor's gonna say the
same thing the only difference between
the doctors is one may kill more than
another that's it there's no requirement
for them to post that you can't tell by
looking at them
Isis looking guy that's the one that
kills the most so this is that for food
group plate grilled chicken breast scene
vegetables some berries there with some
auric points a lot of great organic rice
and millet I guarantee you a couple of
things about looking at that plate
number one there's four minerals that I
can guarantee for minerals there's some
sulfur in the chicken breast because it
was required for the essential amino
acids it has to have some sulfur Metheny
and cysteine cysteine I can also
guarantee there's some magnesium there
because that's what makes that broccoli
grain right everything else all the
other plant materials have magnesium
phosphorus potassium they might not have
any minute magnesium in here the only
magnesium a plant may have only been in
the leaves so but there's some magnesium
here so there's four minerals sulfur
magnesium phosphorus that's all I can
guarantee there's some beta carotene and
the carrots there's some org points
antioxidants in the berries there may be
some Listeria in the cantaloupe killya
and so the only way to guarantee you're
going to get all 90 essential nutrients
is to supplement you supplement again
your vegetables your proteins your fats
which say didn't put in the other side
they said carbohydrates or they said
grains with what they said was grains
but they left out the FAFSA piece so I
had the FAFSA you'll see in a moment why
and then fruits embarrassin but the only
way to guarantee you're going to get
everything you need there is the 90/60
middle 16 by 12 essential amino acids
are essential fatty acids you must
supplement every day like we do for dogs
and cats and chickens and turkeys and
ducks and sheep and pigs and horses and
so on
now how many you're born between 1946
and 1964 raise your hand okay good
that's half the people in the room okay
your baby boomers and your you have a
problem you listen to doctors because
doctors convinced you if you listen to
them you'd be the first generation where
everybody lived to be a hundred Houston
we have a problem because everything
that doctors told you about health is
wrong everything they've told you is
wrong because it's designed to direct
you towards treatment programs as
opposed to cures and Prevention's so
about three years ago my wife and I came
up with our most recent book I got a
couple more in the pipeline here coming
out for next year
but three years ago he came out with
immortality and we looked at the top 20
longevity cultures on earth that were
written up by the National Geographic we
were 60 years worth of national
Geographics looking for this stuff right
we did this in a 10-year period and we
went to four of these cultures and
countries we went to the internet and
books and reference materials for the
others and what we did was look at the
agricultural departments the
anthropology departments and looked at
everything the ate how many calories
they took in there an average life span
all that kind of stuff right now it's
interesting to me that of the top 20
longevity cultures in a single first
world country or industrialized nation
all of the top into 20 longevity
cultures are third world cultures are
illiterate no doctors no hospitals no
clinics no pharmacies no
private or government insurance I mean
if you were to put put a piece of paper
all in a dead gymnasium out there with
all the assets of each country without
the name of the country you would not go
to the top 20 longevity cultures on
earth because they don't have anything
do you think it's being important for
health no doctors an ambulance service
no 911 come on man knows no
pharmaceuticals no hospitals no clinics
they have no they have no utilities that
should begin to ring a bell
you have no utilities and they're their
common fuel is wood and by dumb luck by
dumb luck all the trees that they use
for fuel grow in a place it has all 60
essential minerals and they put those
plant minerals aka wood ashes all 60
essential metals in their gardens and
their open their peas and there's sweet
potatoes and they eat them and they get
all the nutrients you see it's not
technology your good genes that make
them live the long it says they're
getting the basic raw material to
maintain themselves and we give you all
this information in this book I mean
this book should be a revelation to
people okay it has 90 essential
nutrients and they all come from
different ecosystems islands mountains
deserts tropical forests so we show you
how all these different cultures get
there 90 essential nutrients they all
live on a calorie restricted diet how
many of you ever heard of the calorie
restricted type thing okay a few of you
well there's a there's a science on
calorie restriction where if you eat a
perfect diet biochemical you have all
the vitamins and minerals and amino
acids and fatty acids out of amount for
your weight and you cut your calories in
half and maintain that perfect
biochemical piece it'll double your
lifespan there's no doubt about it
now these people are illiterate they
don't have any books if you gave him a
book on the calorie strict you said they
just look at pretty pictures there's no
pictures in there they use the book for
fuel right they can't read and so why
would they all be on a calorie
restricted diet because they're so poor
they can only afford 900 calories a day
they're hanging on by their fingernails
but calorie standpoint yet they work 12
hours a day six days a week because they
have
perfect source and minerals two-thirds
of their essential nutrients Americans
taken 2800 calories to 32 hundred
calories three times with these people
take in and our diet sucks now they
don't get any bad things it's not that
they wouldn't eat these things if they
were there if they're there but by
default
nobody's gonna build a drive-through for
three guys in a borough there's no cars
no roads and so by a default they're not
getting fried foods and processed meats
with nitrates and nitrites in it and
they're not getting any carbonated
drinks okay and then they do get 20
times the 50 times the antioxidants we
do you have 20 times the 50 times and ER
sodas we do Americans take in 1500 or
ack points o RAC is an acronym or
abbreviation for oxygen radical
absorbance capacity which is a
measurement of how many free radicals
being neutralized by the anti our
sensitive food or supplement that's the
US Department of Agriculture or
measurement and what they're doing is
tracking it they they test how many art
points should take in they say okay I'm
people taking in a hundred thousand or
eight points every day don't get cancer
that's what they're looking for some
number like that right that's why
they're doing it well Americans take in
1500 auric points a day 1500 and these
third world cultures take in 20,000
50,000 a day okay they're getting like
15 to 20 times what we take in or more
maybe 40 times so in some cases so these
are things that we thought were
important okay now if you just take the
antioxidant piece has one 25th to the
the recipe and you'll still diet 68 to
72 just taking a super juice it'll make
you live 30 seconds longer you need the
other 24 pieces of the recipe to
particularly the 2/3 which are the
minerals right let's look at
billionaires billionaires our
billionaires because they have a net
worth of at least 1 billion dollars now
Forbes magazine looked at them and I've
been after him for like 10 years there
any Studies on what kills billionaires
no no no no for years years finally in
2004 they came out of the study so I
take a little bit of credit for
for ten years to do that what kills
billionaires they say billionaires are
killed by the same unglamorous things to
kill everybody else stroke heart attacks
diabetes obesity cancer kidney failure
suicide all the stuff that kills
everybody else kills millionaires right
the average lifespan of billionaires by
2004 was 78
we average lifespan were falling down
red wine drunk in Minneapolis 275 you
don't gain a whole lot in longevity by
being a billionaire and then I want you
to think about it there's not as of 2004
there had never been a billionaire
living a hundred now think about it how
many ever seen these newspaper reports
birthdays or death certificates or
deaths of people who are one hundred ten
hundred so any kind of thing
has anybody ever seen a white Harvard
doctor live to be 100 and those better
know they're always a little old black
lady in East Texas in
panhandle of Florida and Louisiana
Western West Virginia in the mountains
someplace in the swamps Louisiana
[Music]
because they have no utilities my dumb
luck the trees are using for fuel and
the 60 essential minerals in it
and all the people with high technology
died younger
well they didn't like that so they made
him redo it and in March of 2011 they
redid it for his magazine redid it in
March of 2011 they said there's still
not been a billionaire it would be a
hundred but the average lifespan did
change it went from 78 in 2004 to 66 and
2011 they lost 12 years of average
lifespan following the doctor's
instructions now the peak of American
longevity occurred 20 years ago has been
dropping an ever-accelerating rate since
then women used to live 10 years longer
than men
well now it's only 3 years longer than
that if we're taking within another 10
years women and men will die the same
age on the average now what's going on
here
that's because baby boomers have
depended on technology they weren't
getting the nutrition and it's starting
to show up now here's a guy intelligent
as you can get my iPod iPad iPhone this
guy was a genius in market he was a
genius electronics and computers I mean
you got to give this guy credit when it
came to healthy he was an idiot he dies
a 56 10 years before the average
lifespan
there was billion in turn so what
happened here well when you're a
billionaire you can afford the best
personal trainer the best food the best
chef cooks the way the doctor wants them
to cook you get all the organics you
want I mean you can get the best health
care plans you can find the most
expensive maybe not the best doctors but
certainly the most expensive doctors if
there's a health thing you need
someplace you can send your plane and
your pilot to go get it you can have
them take you someplace if you take out
the billionaire's by themselves look at
them as a separate demographic
should be the healthiest and longer
people in America shouldn't have money
meant anything for health don't you
think yeah okay so why is it he died of
56 because he he was a veggie dish you
know he was a vegan how many knew he was
a vegan he was a vegan he was a nun
supplemented vegan didn't supplement
because he got the very best organic
food he's a vegan unsub lamented vegan
because he got the very best and his
chef made him the very best organic
vegetables stir-fried an extra extra
extra extra extra virgin virgin virgin
virgin olive oil and as a result from
all the free radicals he got pancreatic
cancer
now here came the juncture in the road
he should have gone to the Nicoya
Peninsula in Costa Rica and Central
America because that's where the longest
live people on earth live the people who
lived the longest on earth live in the
Nicoya Peninsula on the Pacific coast of
Costa Rica there's no doubt about they
outlive everybody about ten years so he
should have gone there and found the
oldest of old person you know a
great-great-great great-great-great
grandmother said great-great great-great
great-great grandma I want you to feed
me like you've been eating now won't you
give me the herbs you would give
somebody with really advanced cancer and
he'd still be alive today if he did but
instead he went to the most decorated
the most heralded research cancer doctor
BAM he was dead
as sure as they shot him in the head
they killed him
and now you know as Paul Harvey would
say the rest of the story
now how many you think that exercise is
good for I raise your hand what do you
believe it or not how many view heard
that exercise go let me rephrase it okay
I think everybody's heard that exercise
is good for you well exercise one of the
most dangerous enterprises you can be
involved in exercise kills more
Americans and terrorists when you
exercise you sweat don't you when you
exercise you sweat when you do physical
work you're throwing bales of hay you're
on the roof roofing your carpenter your
plumber you're working at a steel mill
and all the blast furnace and heat
you're sweating right and people who
love you want to take care of you see
they know your sweat and then your
exercise you know you peewee league you
know or Pop Warner leagues are these
little bitty kids out there exercising
men women doesn't matter gender age you
see look honey I want you to take plenty
of what water so you can re hydrate and
that's what kills you this is what kills
you because sweat is not water sweat is
a soup that contains all the nutrients
floating around in your blood so you're
sweating out this soup you're placing
with water now that's kind of like your
car's leaking a quart of oil every week
yeah I'm not gonna spend the dollar
ninety-nine oh that old clunker so you
put a quart of water in there what's
gonna hit by the third or fourth week
your engine is a big ball of flame and
burn it up right I mean even a idiot
living under the bridge who's gonna
steal your car is gonna check the oil
before he steals it right why would your
risk of freedom or taking a car with no
oil in it okay so it's problematic as a
result as a result you take all
professional athletes together all
sports there his lifespan is 62 you take
football players only this just came out
two years ago I actually have the papers
if you want me
prove it if their average lifespan
professional football players 51 and
with the exception three black guys from
the old Negro baseball league days back
in the 1920s there's never been a
professional athlete ever lived be 100
there's never been a billionaire live to
be a hundred so I'll use all the things
that you think of as being important for
health and longevity aren't real III
speak for hours on on athletics I deal
with professional teams and Olympic
teams and so on let me just show you
this you've all heard ACL injuries and
cartilage injuries and tendon injuries
and muscle things these guys get ten
million dollars a game this is what
happens so I mean I'm supposed to be the
fit of the fittest there drinking water
or Gatorade if they're drinking Gatorade
or eighty-eight charge they're making
water they're hunter shark not a shark
don't you look at my left hand my left
hand is the nutritional reserves in the
body and here you are you're sweating
working out whatever you're doing you're
sweating and you're drinking water
what's happening your nutritional
reserves you're going down because
you're replacing soup with water right
you reach a point which your tendons
can't maintain themselves they break
down you go a little farther you're
Carlos starts shredding got a little
farther you get diabetes and heart
disease a little farther BAM you're dead
and now again you know the rest of the
story I love what are we sell water but
I've put a lot of things in it
here's a guy wanted to be a professional
quarterback had three ACL injuries in
his knee
how many knees does a guy have Elizabeth
Taylor had seven hip replacements how
many hips did Elizabeth Taylor have you
see there's no a lot requiring a doctor
to cure you there's always you only
accept treatment you have good insurance
well insurance pay for it go ahead doc
so make a long story short because of
all the athletes who work because we
came out with a oh I should tell you one
other piece and that is each year
according to the Center for Disease
Control seventy five thousand one
hundred thousand young people in America
75 thousand one hundred thousand young
people in America die each year while
they're exercising under age of thirty
now wait a minute supposed to be good
for you Yeah right who told you that
the doctors told you exercise is good
for you
don't take any vitamins minerals drink
plenty of water hmm and so we came up
with a sports drink called rebound has a
hundred nutrients in it so if you have
somebody you love who's sweating in
their labor or their because they play
sports you need to get them on the
rebound it has a hundred nutrients in it
let's look at doctors u.s. news report
February 5th
excuse me February 2005 US News World
Report rated America's most credible
print news source special health issue
who needs doctors your future physician
might not be a medical doctor may be
better off now do you think that every
MD in Apple Valley made sure this was in
their waiting room and that came out and
I don't think so I think probably they
sent out the Boy Scout Troop there the
David hem will give you a thousand bucks
just go collect all those magazines out
of every store and shred him by a lot of
tents now why did they do that well they
did that because they backed a the
doctors against the HMOs in the 1990s
how many remember that great battle
between the HMOs and the doctors the
doctor said where the doctor here we're
supposed to be the ones to decide what
treat me you get why would you want an
account in an HMO decide and what treat
me to get that's because it
the HMO knew of the HMO can only be
profited profitable if they cured you
they were going for the Cure the doctors
wanted to treat you for 25 years and
everybody went with a doctor
everybody was the doctor you'd been
better off the home of the HMOs cuz they
wanted to cure you doctor didn't like
that well my original audio cassette
tape April of 1993 I said it was a study
based on a database of 200 doctors I
just grabbed a handful of of general
American Medical Association on the
medical library ended up the age of
death of 200 doctors divided by 200 I
got 58 and why would you want to go to
in this seat honey who can said say no
why would you want to go to a group of
people whose average lifespan is 58 to
learn how to lose beyond health away
didn't didn't make sense to me
well they didn't like that so they did
their own study and they said Wallach
lied Tara's life spent apropos of a
family doctor or primary care physician
is not 58 like wallet claims is 56
now some people get the math pretty
quick here I said 58 they said 56 there
was so eager to show that my statistics
were wrong that they failed to
appreciate that they're telling people
that they died two years earlier than I
said so I do apologize for giving him
two too many years so the information
still the same why would you go to a
group of people whose average lifespan
is 56 to learn how they'd be 100 this
fella here Socrates a great
international soccer player is also a
cardiologist who the villain who's a
cardiologist my wife loved this guy just
cause he's good-looking young men my
wife 70 years old she said I'm a cougar
so she thought this cute guy you know
just so cute that's about honey he's
dead because he only drank water I'm
gonna show you my favorite obituary my
favorite obituary is George Francis died
112 he's the oldest man in America in
December of 2008
he's an illiterate black fella from the
swamps Louisiana so he already know
where I'm going
never went to kindergarten as his
daughter reading the newspaper to him
couldn't
never had a job break out a paycheck
with deductions in it and so he he never
had any Social Security never had any
Medicare Medicaid never went to a doctor
using grandma's herbs use wood for fuel
and still drank a lot of white lightning
rolled his own cigarettes that kind of
stuff eight rod ads and you know fried
catfish and sweet potatoes and onions
eight peppers like the Creoles and he
dies 112 is the oldest man in America
mm-hmm no these guys who did this
obituaries Mart they said he lived
through 19 US presidents whose average
lifespan is 75 every lifespan of the US
president 75 when you take out Jack
Kennedy is Saturday at 40-something
right and they have at least one
University green let's roll or they have
to they're cared for by medical doctors
who have at least one universe well they
actually have two universities an
undergraduate degree in a medical degree
and then if they're a specialist like me
they have three four degrees okay and
the average lifespan of the medical
doctors by their own statistics who care
for these presidents of 56 exactly half
of George's age so I don't know what
George do right and so when he died
these authors asked his daughter what
did your daddy do to Libby 112 and she
said he broke all the rules of healthy
eating who came up with rules of healthy
eating
medical doctors will live to be 56 says
he broke all the rules that healthy
eating with a diet heavy on dairy eggs
and large sandwiches nothing but
cholesterol and saturated fat whoo
[Laughter]
now we laugh at that but there's a
message here there's a message here it's
part of that book in mortality when you
see what these people eat you didn't
blow your mind just the obvious what
doctors say is good for you and so why
did he live the 112 eating eggs dairy
and lard sandwiches because cholesterol
and saturated fat is not bad remember I
told you everything doctor soy bad
health is wrong and you're gonna see why
in a minute you're going to be angry
angry angry at the Medical Group okay
this gal here Credle evans little black
lady came to us and this is Bob and Judy
Bell some of our distributors in
Crockett Texas just outside of it
Houston and they sponsored this gal
fifteen years ago and she was 85 years
old and she had like six disease she had
high pressure diabetes arthritis Mac
degeneration she had a little dementia
and we changed her diet we got around
the 90 essential nutrients appropriate
her body weight and 15 years later until
July 8th of this year she turns 100 she
has a very large youngevity business she
got over 300 people in her little
marketing group more than pays for her
supplement she has a lot of money left
over so she goes and does all these
activities all over the place and she to
me she looks like she's maybe 75 to 80
years old she doesn't look like she's
100 as she doesn't color her hair I just
I was really brilliant we're starting to
get more and more people like her we're
accumulating quite a few people and we
might want to do a story on her about
this okay really super stuff the last
one to show you here before I get to the
individual disease I'm gonna go very
fast in the individual diseases got your
pens and paper you'll get most of it
here the last one will show you before I
get to the diseases is this one this is
the oldest person we know on earth now
there's probably people who are older
than her but we don't know about them
this gal was born in 1853 in a little
island
in Indonesia with no utilities what was
her fuel okay and we know she was born
then because we we can see the birth
certificates and the baptismal records
at the Dutch Reformed Church the little
island she was born in now in June of
2010 she 157 she's still alive today so
she's 159 no doctors on that island and
since this is a fairly academic group
I'm going to throw this one in here
which I don't often but it's really a
great story when Linus Pauling got his
first of two Nobel Prizes the first
Nobel Prize he got was for studying the
nutrition of genes G's require nutrients
to function you take a gene you throw it
in a bucket of saline water soak a gene
you're a good gene go for it make
something make a protein gene just sits
there like tar baby gene can't do
nothing without nutrients these are all
mature like a factory right you need raw
material you need energy you need
employees you need parts and all this
stuff
well genes are the same way their genes
are just a blueprint uh-oh what did the
genome do for us after we spend a
trillion dollars nothing after 20 years
of mapping out the genome they still
haven't cured the cold they haven't
cured anything because genes by
themselves do nothing they require 90
essential nutrients - ha ha interesting
this new science is called epigenetics
have you heard of the term epigenetics
okay a few of you good now I've been
involved in this for a long time and
this is where it's at because genes will
not work without nutrition and what he
said when he received his first Nobel
Prize for doing research into the
nutrition of genes and chromosomes and
enzymes he said you can trace every
sickness every disease and every ailment
to a mineral deficiency
whoa that's heavy that is heavy
do you think the medical system liked
him no they actually should have got a
third Nobel Prize because he was the one
the first proposed that the double helix
was how the chromosomes and genes were
laid out he proposed it he figured it
out twenty years before Watson and Crick
got their Nobel Prize for it and they
got their idea by reading his stuff and
he was cheated he should have shared
that Nobel Prize with them but they took
his passport away from him because the
doctors insisted he was a communist and
he couldn't go to Europe and study the
gal by the name of Franklin who was
doing all the x-rays stuff to determine
the double helix and he didn't have
email back then okay now here we go
get your pencil paper out we're gonna
run through about six or eight of the
main diseases very quickly here
this is going to be a revelation for you
and I can go fast because now you know
more than doctors you've now become the
most dangerous people in America let's
see we have what about sixty or so
people in here and fifty-seven people
signed the Declaration of Independence
and started the revolution against
England changed the world
those 57 people know they they committed
their lives our fortunes and our sacred
honor those 57 people it doesn't take
much to win this battle but we're gonna
have to be proactive we can't hope and
pray that the doctors are gonna be the
good guys here we can't hope and pray
let's see I can tell by looking at you
but just for just a show of hands how
many of you ladies are still in the
childbearing years okay a good third of
the anyway well maybe two thirds and
women here in the room so I'm going to
spend two minutes on birth defects every
birth defect you can name me in ten
times that many you can't are all caused
by nutritional deficiencies the embryo
there's not a single genetic birth
defect we've eliminated all birth
defects enabled by simply giving them
females preconception nutrition perfect
preconception nutrition
part of conception as all we had to do
is give them good nutrition before they
can see we eliminate all birth defects
I've been doing that in humans for 35
years okay it works like a charm all the
disease you think of her genetic and
humans are not there just deficiencies
of the embryo now why would you know how
many how many different specialties we'd
wipe out if there wasn't another baby
born with a birth defect oh my gosh all
these kids with special needs all these
different agencies raising money to find
research for the Cure hmm we're gonna
look quickly at obesity because we're
the number one obese nation in the world
why are we the number one obese nation
role because doctors and the government
has no idea what causes it I'm here to
tell you I actually have a book out
there called Hell's Kitchen
the subtitle is the cause prevention and
cure of obesity nobody else can claim
that they know that because they did we
would be the number one obese age of the
world okay so it's not a disease of
excess so the reason why we're in such
trouble with obesity is it's not a
disease of excess and that's how the
government the doctors treat is a
disease of excess you need more exercise
you need you less but that's not what
the problem is it's a nutritional
deficiency disease not a calorie
deficiency but a nutrition deficiency
I'll show you that I'll prove that to
you in a second just show you that for
remembrance right remember that one now
according to experts 70 percent of our
kids under the age of 12 are overweight
and 40% of our kids on the age of 12 or
obese which is 30 pounds over their
ideal weight for their height and it has
nothing to do a too much scream time
lack of exercise or eating too much has
nothing to with any of that is a simple
nutritional deficiency but you see
doctors would rather give you a
bone-marrow transplant when you have
iron deficiency anemia than iron
do you understand well we've got the
technology we got to use the technology
let's do lap banding that will fix it
this is one of my favorite obesity
slides
this looks at obesity in adults in 1980
we only had 15 percent Americans obese
between 1919 he was like 12% 15% well
presented 50 Arizona
it never really rose about 15% for 80
years boy in here it just started going
up like crazy by 2020 years later it
doubled more than double what happened
well right here they took all the fat
out of our diet it's hard to find in fat
I mean everything is no fat low-fat or
fat-free and we're getting fat then
anybody here ever raise livestock
anybody fatten cattle or sheep or pigs
now do you feed them ice cream in lard
and eggs to fatten them up do you feed
them whole grains to fan him up
classically the answer is yes you feed
him whole grains
99% of farmers feed their cattle and
pigs and sheep and chickens whole grains
to fatten them up now wait a minute
didn't they tell you to eat whole grains
huh let's have a look at that now you
see this is what you're getting probably
the Dodgers instructions don't fatten
eaten whole grains exercising now if the
doctors were correct the chart should
look like that if the government is
correct this chart should look like that
but follow their directions for 20 plus
12 years is 32 years Oh
houston we have a problem here now one
of my favorite obesity slides is that of
Rosalie Bradford she had two Guinness
World Book of Records for obesity number
one she's the heaviest woman ever
officially weighed by the by the
Guinness World Book of Records she
weighed 1,200 42 pounds one thousand two
hundred and forty-two pounds you went on
two dates with Rosalie you had a ton of
fun do the math
now she also had her second gives rule
book writer she lost the most weight 736
pounds between 1987 1994 this is not
lose 10 gain 5 lose 10 gain 5 our kind
of thing this is lose lose lose lose
because they did a lap banding on her
and they put on a 500 calorie diet and
she over those years she lost 736 pounds
that's like three people okay and then
she died because fat is not the problem
fat is just a symptom just like
cholesterol is not the problem now what
does it tell you in 1980 was it was 15%
it's almost gone up 300% so what's the
problem here that's because they've told
you to get fat
he'd whole grains exercise don't take
vitamins and minerals avoid fat and you
get fat I mean if you're not careful you
could wind up in Ruth's Chris Steakhouse
is the meal instead of instead of the
meter no end in sight for the obesity
epidemic why is that because there's 80
million baby boomers come along we'd
hold reigns exercise don't take vitamins
minerals I'm gonna give you three clues
then I'm gonna give you the answer don't
forget the book at Hell's Kitchen this
gal here natalie Hayhurst from Terre
Haute Indiana was driven to eat light
bulbs now they say it's a rare condition
but it's not a rare condition this
happens with several million times a day
in America she prefers wood paper
products cardboard stick she likes rocks
dirt sheets coke cans phony
classic coke cans only diet coke cans
she's eating little magnets out of
shower curtain she loves plastic bottles
and toys I think that's why McDonald's
took the toy out of the Happy Meal so
what what is this condition well you can
call it Piko the munchies you can call
it you know that kind of stuff but but
she has a condition because she's merely
deficient pregnant women get the same
thing the weird stuff when women
pregnant women or classic reading weird
stuff you know back when your
grandmother was out living on the
ruler's she had pregnancy she won't eat
dirt fortunately there's no calories in
dirt right well ladies heard your
grandma used to eat dirt
she's pregnant yeah I mean grandma used
to do that we live in the 17th floor of
an apartment building now in the inner
city there's no trees even you started
eating the tootsie rolls out of the
kitty litter boxes you're hungry for
weird stuff when you're merely deficient
if you only can't with the Keeler box
you know what I'm talking about so once
you get the book Hell's Kitchen because
that's going to give you the details of
when and how and gives you the whole
story of the electricity and how it made
us fan loyal of School of Medicine
Chicago that's the Russian version again
exercise won't cure obesity because your
exercise you're sweating you're placing
your sweat with water you're sweating
out on your minerals and guess what you
get hungry here if you're skinny you
stay skinny if you're fat you get fatter
you exercise as a result when they
looked at that Dad everybody agreed that
they were correct so as a cover article
in August of 2009 eight months later the
myth about exercise it won't make you
lose weight anybody here to raise horses
or work with horses raise your hand okay
if you what do you call when a horse
shoes on the fence cribbing very good
and how do you get rid of cribbing in a
horse you can shoot him in the head
that'll stop it but I mean what else can
you to get a horse to stop cribbing what
yeah you give a trace metal salt block
or you give them bone meal or some
minerals and they'll stop within three
to five days they'll stop chewing on the
fence
well those you've never seen cribbing
this is a stall in a barn and a horse
and buggy Amish farm in Switzerland
County Indiana in the southeastern
corner of Indiana and I don't even need
to look at the horse or do tests on them
I just look at the rails and this stall
in the barn I can see that that horse is
merely inefficient now it's called
cribbing and animals is called the
munchies in humans now it is socially
unacceptable it's socially unacceptable
for your little kids to eat the
neighbors furniture when you visit
and that's where we developed the custom
that's redeveloped the custom of taking
and giving them cookies and drinks they
all have calories in it
so we came up with a program that works
every time
obviously you have to take the 90
essential nutrient poor bran you ate one
Healthy Start pack for a hundred pounds
of body weight per month and then if
you're a diabetic we like you to throw
in and you don't have to be a diabetic
but certainly a diabetic you could also
throw this in if you're not a diabetic
the slender FX weight management system
it has some gluten free water soluble
fiber so you feel satiated it's got a
meal replaced or you can either make it
into a cold shake or an ice cream you
make it with water and it has 80
calories and no sugar and great for
diabetics I also have some accelerators
here to speed up the weight loss but the
real secret sauce for weight loss is
this one ASAP put a dropper full of this
under your tongue thirty minutes before
each meal and this replaces the HCG diet
how many heard of the HCG diet okay
that requires injections you got to do
this whole thing with the doctor right
prescription stuff well this is the raw
material for your body to make your own
HCG if you put this under your tongue
thirty minutes before each meal and you
will lose weight and keep it off ASAP
ASAP as slim as possible as soon as
possible I'll show you two examples one
boy one girl this is Jerry from Salt
Lake City he builds for 12 years at this
point and he had a bread belly now he'd
been taking the 90s sentence didn't have
any health problems but he had a bread
belly how many ever heard of a beer
belly raise your hand okay sure
well good German knows that beer is
liquid bread every German knows that
beer is liquid bread why because the
ingredients in beer in the ingredients
and bread are exactly the same the only
difference between bread and beer is one
is ferment and the other was baked the
same ingredients same ingredients only
bakers and fermentation is just
difference in preparations the same
stuff so it shouldn't be too hard for
you to understand how somebody who eats
bread you can get a bread belly just
like people who drink beer get it
belly alright so all we added to his
program he's been he just took two
healthy start packs and he drank tit a
rebound because he's a little bit of a
farmer his wife Judy loved to make bread
he had bread for breakfast lunch dinner
and bedtime snack make his wife happy
support his wife's hobby of making bread
organically-grown multigrain and you
know the drill so we added the ASAP 45
days he looses 50 pounds primarily from
his belly ok because this product will
preferentially move your your metabolism
to preferentially burn belly fat and you
can do crunches you can do all that kind
of stuff you can lose 50 pounds you'll
lose muscle before you lose belly fat I
see a lot of people shaking their heads
yes right if you ever tried to lose
belly fat is very difficult but this
stuff will do it now I'll show you
another one here you already know this
person
little redheaded gal brandy who
introduced me she's 5 foot 2 into this
picture
she weighed 158 pounds one third of her
body weight was fat okay I apologize for
this being out of focus but this came
off of her driver's license with a phone
camera Mary so she'd been with us for
about eight years at this point we and
she'd been using her products or her
husband as a heavy equipment driver and
he liked bread so she made bread for him
and what was ever leftover she needed
right rather than let it go away she ate
it and so we put her on the rebound
because she was drinking two litres of
Pepsi a day only five foot two Julia's a
Pepsi day and so we put on rebound
instead of the the Pepsi and then she
lost oh no 28 something pounds and she
still need to lose another 30 so she got
on the ASAP and in a month's time she
got down 206 pounds 158 106
Healthy Start pact rebound and ASAP no
that was I think she got down to this
hundred and six pounds in January of
this year she's still hundred six pounds
you'll keep your weight off as long as
you're taking in the minerals
appropriate if your body weight because
you don't have the munchies anymore
everybody else you can lose weight
there's a million different ways to lose
weight but you always gain it back
because you haven't solved the problem
of mineral deficiency you get the
picture
okay now I can move on here well also I
should do this one here I forgot Tim's
here well the guys who helped register
tonight Tim he lost forty four and a
half pounds and eight inches and weighs
in just 60 days on the program he'd been
with us for a while but the ASAP and
he's been able to keep it off he was
telling me he was hiking up in the
mountains and because he lost that 45
pounds he did pretty good
okay how many ever heard of Al's heart
disease raise your hand okay Allison
disease is a physician cause disease
mm-hmm Al's her disease is a physician
cause disease didn't exist 40 years ago
even by another name today it's the
number four cause of death and Americans
over the age of 65 so it goes from zero
four years ago now it's the number four
cause of death as caused by physicians
I'll tell you how
what is Allison or disease well Allison
Razzies is a going away the mile and is
the white mare to the brain how have you
heard of myelin will see you younger
people should know violence at white
mare the brain insulation material when
it goes away the naked nerve fibers all
tangle up for the diagnostic features of
Allan summers these at autopsy you get
these nerve tangles you probably all
read about nerve tangles and this is
caused by the myelin going away well my
land makes up 75 percent of your brain
weight the gray matter your brain the
thinking part the memory part the
problem-solving part of your brain it
only makes up two percent of your brain
weight it's like two millimeters of this
little
covering or the white man or the white
matter makes up 75 percent of your brain
weight
well this myelin is white mare the brain
that makes up 75% of your brain weight
is a hundred percent cholesterol so you
go on a cluster very strict to diet
you take cholesterol-lowering drugs BAM
you have Alzheimers disease because you
can't maintain the white matter your
brain anymore you given up all the raw
matures you're taking drugs to drive
your cholesterol down because doctors
said it would make you live longer let's
have a look
Alzheimers tidal wave feared why is that
there's 80 million baby boomers come
along they'll listen to doctors lower
their cholesterol with diet and drugs
this came out in 2009 Alexandra's in a
relentless effort triggered kinda
reminds me of that obesity chart finally
doctor's instructions going this way why
because numbers look particularly grim
for baby boomers who follow the doctor's
instructions exercise drink plenty of
water don't eat fat need plenty of whole
grains oh yeah use oils instead of lard
and dairy and eggs like George Francis
oh we're gonna see a lot of this kind of
stuff now a mother and son share the
bonds of love al-harazi's in the same
doctor who lured their cholesterol now
any mormons in here tonight any more
moans any more of them same room
disappointed no more ones okay any
seventh-day adventists any okay the
reason why I'm asking that question is
2004 Johns Hopkins School of Medicine
came out with a wonderful study on Al's
neural disease they went to Cache County
Utah they chose Cache County which I
mean you could get 5,000 people for a
study in Baltimore Maryland right so why
did they go all the way out to Cache
County you Tom let's because in Cache
County you tell they're extremely
religious Mormons are almost like artha
Doc's Jewish people when it comes to
their diet
they actually have a book called the
words of wisdom which supplements the
Book of Mormon and it tells them what to
eat what not to eat right and so all of
these people in Cache County Utah the
oldest living people in America they
live eighty seven seven day Adventists
live eighty five the Mormons as a group
would be eighty five but the the Mormons
in Cache County Utah lived the eighty
seven they're all farmers very religious
farmers with the background from
Scotland they all come just know their
culture it comes from Scotland so
culture the same same genetic pool same
diet their same profession live in the
same County same everything same time it
was really a great study I mean it was
like laboratory rats right it's just
perfect and what they do is take five
thousand these people over the age of
sixty five they gave half of them a
couple of vitamins the other half they
gave a sugar pills a blind setters
nobody knew who was getting what well
the end of the study those getting the
vitamins reduced their risk of Allison
or disease by seventy percent those
getting the sugar pill increase their
Alzheimer's disease risk by seventy
eight percent but you have remember the
diet was the basic thing okay
now in the analyst read we give him the
perfect diet very similar to the Mormon
diet and the Jewish diet in the
seventh-day Adventist diet but we also
add all 90 essential nutrients we
eliminate alzheimers disease and animals
by a hundred percent
so now you know alzheimers disease is
not genetic there's no way it could be
genetic if you can reduce the risk of
heart disease by seventy-eight
percentages by taking a couple of
vitamins in a particular diet it's not
genetic in any way shape or form again
doctors are wrong because their
knowledge is very constricted they have
a very narrow range of training they
know little or nothing
every time they utter the word nutrition
or give you a nutritional advice they
should be put in jail as a felon that
would stop them from killing people they
say the first two letters of the word
nutrition they should be put in jail or
jail put the cuffs on them now give you
an example this is Ray McGregor from
Charlotte North Carolina his sister
who's one of our associates one of our
distributors three years ago called me
and said her brother eight years earlier
had been diagnosed with Alzheimer's
disease very severe very rapidly
advancing the doctors tried all these
drugs they say it can help a dementia no
help so she took him over the eight-year
period before she called me to three
neurological clinics then she took him
to the medical school two weeks before
she called me and went to the department
or ology at the medical school there in
North Carolina and said look I want that
I'm demanding that the head of the
department neurology examine my brother
which he did look at this guy he's
sitting he's curled up on the floor he's
being fed through g2 there's nothing we
do drugs oh my god the love is not gonna
help him money's not gonna help me put
him in a hospice if you're gonna do that
put him in the one that I own right oh
he didn't say that but I just threw that
put him in a house is what he said
mm-hmm so she calls me so there's four
different dimensions there's vaster
dementia which used to be called senile
dementia there's nothing wrong with your
brain when you have seen al to measure
of Astra to mention it's actually a
plugging of the arteries in your brain
just like you get coronary arteries a
plug they can plug here can plug there
right and then there's Korsakoff
syndrome which is a deficiency of a
single vitamin discovered three hundred
years ago
set in the year 1712 by a Japanese naval
surgeon and then there's wernicke
korsakoff's which is Korsakoff syndrome
that deficiency of that vitamin and MS
multiple sclerosis mixed in together
and then there's alzheimers disease so
here's what I told her to do I said look
we're gonna treat him for all four and I
do this literally a thousand times a
year it always works out so we're gonna
try this in your brother - we get into
two healthy start packs he weighed 185
pounds we gave him to a healthy starter
packs got him off all the bad stuff no
fried foods no oils was difficult
because what are they feeding him
through his g-tube ensure which is all
carnival it's easy to get through the
tube miss you count the calories and
that's why they made it out of carnival
they don't consider what it does for the
patient and what it does to the patient
right ensures the worse I wouldn't give
in sure to a communist okay bad stuff so
two healthy start packs per month none
of the bad stuff now for The Bachelor
dementia I threw in three twice a day of
the ultimate daily tabs which are
designed to get blood flow through
beloved arteries and support healthy
blood pressure and so on then for the
korsakoff's syndrome I gave them three D
stress capsules twice is two bottles a
month it has the vitamins in it that are
missing when you have coarse coma
syndrome and then for wernicke
korsakoff's I added selenium to it three
of those twice a day those two bottles a
month to deal with the lesions of the MS
which you can get rid of those and ms
goes away and then for the alton disease
I threw in 12 eggs a day to rebuild the
myelin on the brain because the
cholesterol has gone his brain so I've
got to get ramped up his cholesterol
game 12 eggs a day and three of our what
we call smart FX three times a day
that's three bottles a month ultimate
daily tablets and then last one is smart
FX three of those you're like get smart
okay three of those three times a day at
three bottles a month and that's the raw
materials to your brain to make the
neurotransmitters for memory duh so she
calls me in two weeks I'm gonna give you
an exact quote of what she called me
actually was a week
okay I'm gonna give you the exact quote
she calls me on the radio so I have the
disc
yeah I'm even gonna quote the utterances
she made she calls me intuition she says
he's cured he's cured now ray and his
wife love me because he was that close
to death put him in a hospice he'd been
dead in two weeks okay
now he didn't have Alzheimers disease
like all those doctors said he had
Korsakoff syndrome which is curable in
two weeks by giving him the vitamin
remember I hedge my bet and I've treated
him for all four it paid off for Ray I
do this a thousand times a year maybe
more than that and I don't even know it
but those are the ones I know about I do
have to tell you that sugar aggravates
the deficiency of that vitamin sugar
aggravates the deficiencies that
vitamins so I thought this is kind of
profound and this came out in February
of 2012 this year high calories from
sugar linked to mild memory loss and
elderly here deficient at bottom you're
taking lots of sugar juices and fruit
and molasses and honey and agave syrup
and soft drinks and desserts and candy
bars guess what you're gonna get
dementia but it's not a disease it's
this Korsakoff syndrome or Wernicke
Korsakoff syndrome sugar and oil is the
worst possible thing you give to anybody
the brain problem particularly the
elderly right the same formula works
also on part disease MS multiple
sclerosis as I already mentioned and
also Lou Gehrig's disease ALS thousands
of these people a year were able to
reverse from there's a Julie take 60 90
days I'm very famous in Western Canada
for this or some very wealthy guys had
parks disease and we went back there
three months after we got him go their
wives were very I mean they made him
stick to the thing
they round up everything put a turkey
baster into their g-tubes went back from
three months one of them as he comes all
our meetings and he's very wealthy guy
and I had put all his employees on our
program his name is David Dietrich's he
had all these patents for quick release
and quick coupling tractor equipment and
he comes out to me says hi doc I really
don't remember you but but you're the
guy that saved me I'm the one that used
to have parking season and he was a
vegetable when I first and now he's
perfectly healthy in just three months
and he'd been getting worse worse worse
for 12 years you're very dangerous now
because now you know okay arthritis
90% of all arthritis is a simple mineral
deficiency disease only 2% of arthritis
has rheumatoid arthritis caused by an
infection that's curable in two weeks
you can cure Muhtar thrives in two weeks
with it with antibiotics we've known
that for 70 years I say there's no law
requiring doctors are curious so how do
they treat you and let's see here they
give you prednisone cortisone they give
you a methotrexate they give you gold
shots they do joint replacements
$750,000 why should they take $300 in
office calls see now you become very
dangerous now becuase now you know the
truth 85% of the people who ruin which
arthritis also have bone to bone
arthritis so you still even with
rheumatoid arthritis even though it's an
infection when it's advanced they're all
knurled up even people like that within
a year we can get him playing concert
piano we've done it hundreds of times
you know they're all knurled up no
surgeries no joint images just come
within a year
they've repair it's an amazing thing
okay
given the healthy bone and joint pack
you throw in what we call the the killer
biotic kind of like Geraldine's
boyfriend killer mmm
so he may recognize this fella Andy
young he'll civil rights movement this
is 1991 I was a little porkier back then
she had about sixty pounds since then
but Andy was scheduled to get a double
knee replaced because he had bone to
bone arthritis nineteen
anyone athletes told him about me so he
called me and said can you help me at a
yacht and he cancelled his double knee
replacement surgeries and that was 21
years ago it's never had to have any
joint surgery and he's perfectly healthy
now in his 80s he can outrun an 18 year
old and swims 5 miles a day creeping on
my program for 21 years the coming up
epidemic for the thricewise are coming
epidemic of arthritis as because there's
80 million baby boomers all of this and
the doctors exercise is good for you
drink plenty of water do not take any
vitamins minerals you can overdose now
do you think they did that just because
they were stupid and because they were
protecting their trophy wife's lifestyle
hmm this came out September 2000 2012
twenties soaring knee surgeries put a
strain on cost why is that because
there's 80 million baby boomers come
along and they all want knee surgeries
because the doctors insurance pay for it
why would I want to pay $4 a day to
rebuild my knee when insurance pays for
surgery because when you do surgery on
your right knee what does that do for
the other 71 joints your body nothing
you take the healthy bone and joint pack
and support some promotes maintenance
repair of all of them
well I better ask my doctor I get that a
lot I better ask my doctor
you better hurry he's 75 years and 11
and a half months old he's only got two
weeks left
do not take those drugs of miss
phosphates pazzo Max and boniva
they only reduced the rate of loss of
brittle old bone they do not build new
bone as doctors told you that's why it's
now 1 800 bad drug Harvard Medical
School New England Journal of Medicine
ten years ago 2002 no alien Journal of
Medicine they did a meta study on
300,000 people that had joint
replacement surgeries knees hips
shoulders they just you reporters just
she's near surgery because everybody
knows about nature knee surgery aka all
joint surgeries for arthritis are
worthless
that's Harvard Medical School in the New
England Journal of Medicine ten years
ago but you go to any orthopedic surgeon
say all I've got bone to bone or I
suppose knees and all these other
doctors want to do joint replacement
sorry well I'll do a better job and give
you a 10% discount do any of them say
hey let's try the healthy bone and joint
pack for 90 days here and then we'll
decide about surgery no no no so what I
want you to do is give youngevity give
me 90 days do the healthy bone and joint
pay if you have any joint problems I
have to tell you I'm 73 years old I've
been doing this for 64 years I started
when I was nine I started taking nothing
healthy bone and joint pack the way it
is but the 90 essential nutrients twice
a day she says nine years old read the
book dead dodging a lie tells you the
story how I figured it out when I was
nine I figured that I had a little help
right no nine year olds gonna figure it
out then so a most had some help but
think about it
I haven't been sick one day in 64 years
people know me for a long time I've
never been sick in 64 I've never been on
a prescription medication never I can
still get another eight hours of lecture
on one foot if I can balance myself here
I mean not many 73 year old guys who
didn't do that because they have
arthritis and pain in their feet in the
back songs cause stuff and so it has
nothing to do with age it has to do with
everything you're giving your body all
the raw materials it needs to maintain
itself you put all in your car you
change the oil every 3,000 miles like
the maintenance book says that car will
last 300,000 miles you don't change you
all and you don't replace it as it's
burning up
you might only go 50,000 miles right so
it give me 90 days if I fail you can
always get the surgery if you go get the
surgery first you can't always get unser
gee not infected unparallel eyes on dead
four years later the same group of
doctors same database looked at back
surgery low back pain sciatica restless
leg syndrome peripheral neuropathies
numbness burning tingling in your neck
and feet and hams and so forth
degenerative disc disease surgery
unnecessary for sciatica and low back
pain low back problems give me 90 days
if I fail you with a healthy bone and
joint pack you could always right you
can always go get the surgery but you
don't want to go get surgery first
because of all the terrible things that
they do to patients fitted back surgery
that's the worst I see you all the time
they're all girls
oh yeah they put two rods in my back 14
years ago and I'm doing fine now
everything's good yeah
give me 90 days okay diabetes is a
simple mineral deficient disease is not
genetic in any way shape or form we've
known that for seven years it's a simple
nutritional deficiency disease but again
doctors are not obligated to cure you
when there's a cure available there are
protected monopolies they can do what
they want and as long as you agree to it
everybody's happy
why is it gonna be a diabetes epidemic
80 million baby boomers come home
exercise sweat out your nutrients drink
plenty of water
don't take vitamins you can overdose I
must hear that a thousand times a day if
I hear at once I know who to strangle
first the patient or the doctor and
here's why he'll be bearing your
children Wall Street Journal April of
this year no easy cure for diabetic
children now we're not talking about
type 1 this is type 2 it used to be
called adult onset type 2 diabetes
because it only occurred in people over
the age of 50 well that was a long time
ago in 1963 people under the age of 5
never got
look following the doctors and
government sustainable grains don't eat
fat you know plenty of exercise don't
supplement look what him if the doctors
were right in the government is right
the chart should look like that again
following the instructions doing what
they say this is what you're getting and
so the kids are dying younger and
younger and younger just from type-2
diabetes when nobody should get it's a
simple mineral deficiency high blood
sugar is not the disease high blood
sugar is just a symptom to see just like
elevated blood cholesterol is a symptom
of type 2 diabetes it has nothing to do
with the cause of the disease
how about sugar do not get statin drugs
because they increase your risk of
diabetes type 2 diabetes by 50% this
came out what in 2012 right just like
the other one I showed you I don't get
all the easy ones when I get people with
diabetes I usually get them with
complications here's some gangrene of
the foot
I see gangrene and legs all the way up
to the groin and a good endocrinologist
he loves this I mean the toes are
crystallizing there's not much healthy
flesh left so look up the foot off right
there at the arch if it goes up the leg
but cut the leg off in the middle of the
thigh or up at the groin well with our
program usually takes 2 to 14 days to
wean them off their medication now
they're an X I bet akin 2 to 14 days it
happens like all the time the longest it
ever takes is 30 60 days but I'd say 80%
of them are 2 to 14 days if they do
exactly as I say they'll we know if
their medication because we're giving
them the mineral that's missing but what
about the complications what about
blindness what about heart disease what
about gangrene we'll just all goes away
usually 30 to 60 days we didn't have to
have one thing for January it's called
the ultimate daily tablet just like for
vascular dementia in coronary artery
disease for this way I'd also add in
addition to the healthy blood sugar pack
which is the healthy starter pack in the
sweeties appropriate for body weight if
they have complications of the heart our
eyes or brain or complicate
the gangrene given the ultimate daily to
get the circulation going here's another
one the shows they don't know anything
diabetes cases may double by 2050 and
perhaps even triple no what does it tell
you about their level of knowledge when
it comes to the cause of these they
don't nothin other dude was tracking
numbers and treating the same way over
and over and over
I remember Albert Einstein he here's a
Nobel Prize when I'm one of my favorites
and he said many global things are
unimpeachable my favorite is insanity is
doing the same thing over and over and
expecting a different result he's the
one that came up with that what a
beautiful global statement right and
this just shows how stupid and insane
they are so again the healthy blood
sugar pact if they have complications
whatever is necessary to do with the
complications usually within 2 to 14
days or a next abetik so it's not
cholesterol the plugs the arteries what
is it it's inflammation cause the arms
beating fried foods and eating oils and
processed meats with nitrates and
nitrites all the things that turn into
trans fatty acids even a room
temperature you go to a restaurant while
we're very careful ask we want salad but
we want to dry we don't want any
dressing on it you know when I go to a
restaurant I have all my eggs poached at
home I'll soft scramble my eggs and
butter because I know I'm using butter
if I ask the cook in the I hopper a
Denny's to scramble my eggs and butter
you know they're gonna do they're using
honey it tastes like butter because it's
cheaper and they think they're doing me
a favor because it's you know it's an
oil or margin I want to be like George
Francis would be 112 at least ok
the secret killer is not cholesterol
it's have you heard of Saturday Post see
young people don't even know it I
thought it was a dead magazine tendon
even though it's still existed this is a
May June 2012 issue cover article fill
pill shocker cholesterol meds maybe
useless they left out two words they
should have said cholesterol meds may be
useless and dangerous articles title was
a cholesterol conundrum
one of the doctors interviewed for the
information that article said everything
you've heard about cholesterol and heart
disease
we'll call everybody that doctors and
then a summary of speaking to 12
different doctors these these authors of
this article spoke to 12 different
doctors who were primarily heads of the
departments of Cardiology of medical
school said is the summary cholesterol
levels are actually a fairly weak
predictor who will have a heart attack
what what now this is just the opposite
what they said even two weeks before
this article came out now I said this in
71 they thought it was an idiot now
they're saying what I said 41 years
earlier okay cholesterol levels are
actually a fairly weak predictor who
will have a heart attack because that's
true
cholesterol has nothing to do with a
heart attack you saw this one earlier
now this will mean something to you good
cholesterol not so beneficial higher HDL
high density lipoproteins a good
cholesterol levels don't reduce heart
attack
lower your cholesterol of any kind good
or bad doesn't reduce heart attacks does
none cause it he spent a trillion
dollars a year for 50 years for nothing
he spent all that money and all that
energy and all that consideration eating
stupidly and you're ranked 92nd the role
in healthfulness 60th longevity that's
what you got for following the doctor's
instructions well these other people out
there doing just the opposite with
doctors say just cause are illiterate
live to be hundred twelve pediatricians
went in on the largesse now they want to
get the kickbacks to that are gonna
start giving eight-year-olds statin
drugs to lower their cholesterol because
they think if we lower the cholesterol
levels and kids eight years old will
prevent heart disease and addons
and what you're gonna say is no do not
let them give your kids
cholesterol-lowering drugs because they
will die before they're 20 and you will
be standing a gravesite bearing your
children the last thing we share with
you is my favorite article on
cholesterol will talk about high blood
pressure I'll be done this is the last
one close for almost my favorite article
on cholesterol normal cholesterol an 88
year old man was calling Frank who eats
25 eggs a day polished in the New
England Journal Medicine this is not a
big study this is a case report but it's
very valuable this guy Frank goes in 88
years old for his annual physical the
doctor Kern who's a clinical doctor in
the out page
a clinic at Harvard Medical School which
teaches you know young doctors how to be
doctors and that's scary and dr. Kern
comes to Franken says look you're pretty
good shape for 88 years old man we
couldn't find anything wrong with you
I'm gonna reward you I'm gonna give you
a prescription of Viagra so Frank stands
up kind of lifts up his belt you know
and throws his shoulders back says I'm
pretty good in that area I don't need no
viagra says actually really what what do
you do what do you do to be good neder
he says well I eat 25 eggs a day the
doctors what the doctor is having a
heart attack what you need 25 eggs a day
so doctor runs it back in the lab and he
reruns it himself he couldn't believe
the numbers so he comes banks as well
your blood cholesterol is 190 without
medication and why do you eat 25 eggs a
day says well BAM it makes me more
studly know what you think about it how
many of you heard of estrogen
progesterone okay that's to see roid
hormones
how have you heard of adrenal hormones
okay that's another serum how many heard
testosterone
it's another steroid hormones those four
hormones are steroid hormones and
they're ninety-five percent by weight
cholesterol so you going to a
cholesterol restricted diet you take
cholesterol-lowering drugs ain't nobody
home anymore
okay you have a rectal dysfunction
that's why they have so many ads on TV
after 10 o'clock at night there's Bob
selling insight and the one I really
love is cialis you know this couple on
the beach in the bathtubs now their
genetic line who's gonna die out there
very stupid you got to be in the same
bathtub before there's the right moment
I mean two slabs of cast iron is between
you ain't nothing gonna happen no matter
how good your erection is right now
so heat six to eight eggs a day and you
know Ted and his wife Nasim and Brandi
they always eat with me a lot in the
road when I go to these places I'll have
a big steak if it's breakfast time I'll
have four eggs that are poached with a
big hamburger patty or a breakfast steak
and you can see all the people in their
place they're eating their organic
multigrain waffles looking at me and
they don't even know they're dead men
walking
so you take your 90 essential nutrients
we actually have an aphrodisiac called
drive it's a little capsule and and the
main ingredient is an urban it's an
Asian herb called horny goat weed it's a
great little herb called dr we add that
to our out a couple of other things a
lot of fun okay the stealth killer high
blood pressure is a simple mineral
deficiency how it pressure is not
genetic in any way shape or form even in
the black community it's not genetic
millions don't manage below the blood
pressure well that's because they're
treating symptoms or they're not dealing
with the cause causes and mineral
deficiency salt has nothing to do with
high blood pressure what's the first
thing a good farmer Rancher puts out for
his livestock in the pasture a salt
block or Salt Lick right there's nobody
on that pasture telling a cow she's
limited in one lick a day is there I
refuse to believe my human patients are
dumber than a cow oh also if your blood
biblically orientated it's kind of fun
God said go forth and be a salt to the
earth right I mean it's in the Bible and
God is forever now doctors say restrict
sultanate little b56 I'm going with God
big sunny Oh houston we have a problem
here low sodium intake could be riskier
that's because sodium is an essential
nutrient you cannot have nerve impulses
without sodium can't move water around
your body beyond sodium you can't make
stomach acid without chloride chloride
and sodium are probably the most common
of all the mineral cofactors necessary
for enzymes and genes to work Oh houston
we have a problem now while this study
was designed to deal with high blood
pressure in the black community because
doctors convinced the black community
that have a pressure is genetic in them
this also is true for heat whites and
blacks and yellows and reds and oranges
and everybody right what they do is go
from Loyola University in Chicago in
Oxford University in London to Nigeria
they want to go up in the mountains of
Nigeria and find some tribal guys that
had normal blood pressure you take their
blood samples and they make a vaccine
come back to genetically engineered
thing injected in every black man woman
and child and get rid of pellet pressure
that way well they get out to Nigeria
from from Oxford University and Loyola
University and they find out that only
7% of the people living in the tribal
areas of Nigeria have high blood
pressure 93% of normal that freaked him
out to go back to London they go back to
Chicago they start doing DNA tests
looking for gene pools of people whose
ancestors had originated from West
Africa during the slave trading days in
the 1670 hundred they found lots of them
they started just simply screening by
doing blood pressures that found out
that the people the same genetic pool is
from West Africa as the West Africans 33
percent have it pressure so you know me
it's not genetic because your position
on earth doesn't dictate or change how a
genetic disease will manifest itself if
you have genetic disease here you know
and Minneapolis are gonna have it in
London you're gonna have it in Cape Town
South Africa you're gonna have an
Auckland New Zealand doesn't matter what
your honor the Jag does even be the same
so when there's a five times difference
here between your where you live you
know it's not genetic and well they
didn't like that so they gathered up
more more blood samples from Nigeria
more blood samples from all over the
world from people who had originated
from
Nigeria their ancestors during the slave
trading days and they got in the
geneticist and they got in the
cardiologist and the blood pressure
people all this stuff and they studied
for six years and in 2005 January 2005
they came out with the final results of
the study
remember doctors once you believe that
its genetic this is published in the
British Medical Journal which is their
version of the journal the american
medical social and here's what they said
hold on to your hands high blood
pressure and blacks not genetic help
fish and whites not genetic high blood
pressure and yellows not genetic have
exposure and Red's not genetic it's not
genetic anybody it says simple mineral
deficient disease
now how many of you in this room
particularly the black individuals in
this room how many of you had your
doctor send you an email
in 2005 things praise God we just
learned that high blood pressure in
blacks not genetic
he's take a healthy start packing the
old urban daily tablets blood pressure
goes away in a couple weeks
hallelujah anybody get that I speak to
black churches all the time they've
never heard of that you know how many
black men have died in the last seven
years because they didn't get the
information or 100,000 from a high blood
pressure stroke somebody needs to go to
jail mm-hmm but they won't because
they're protected monopoly so how do we
deal with this we tell people ourselves
we share this information and get people
to do things for themselves they won't
need doctors here comes the fun part
in August of 2003 in the journal the
American Medical Association of all
things JAMA the Journal of American
Medical Association in August of 2003
there was a big article in there about
an herb that lowers blood pressure it
has flavanols then it's called dark
chocolate not milk chocolate not
Hershey's bars but dark chocolate has a
substance in it called flavanols which
lowers blood pressure now doesn't solve
the problem of the mineral deficiency
but it will act like a plant in medicine
herbs are
it'll lower your blood pressure so you
don't have a stroke until you you're
taking enough minerals for you to
eliminate it permanently right but I
just keep taking it because I like it
my blood pressure I'm 73 years old my
blood pressure is 121 over 71 my blood
my pulse is 43 it does spike when I get
any real spike up to 45 when I get angry
when I was wrestling for the University
of Missouri my resting pulse was 38 and
the doctors are always freaking out but
I could always outrun them out with them
and all of a sudden the other right and
in addition dark chocolate has another
substance it's a fun substance called P
EAS phenol f la means how many you're
heard of phenol f la means okay this is
a reason why we give chocolate on
Valentine's Day because the phenol f
lemis now the Spanish they didn't know
the name of the chemical but they knew
there was something special about dark
chocolate so in 1523 they took out to
Europe and started giving it away on
Valentine's Day is the whole purpose of
dark chocolate was to seduce the woman
the dark chocolate piays phenethylamines
or the love chemicals they're an
aphrodisiac right it's really great
stuff it's got to be dark chocolate so
in that year 2003 we came out with a
product called cocoa gemma tea and cocoa
jeopardy has flavanols it will lower
your blood pressure but it's also loaded
with PJs yep it always works guys so
when Valentine's comes up and it's
coming up in a couple of months don't
give chocolates give cocoa jibbety and
reap the awards reap the rewards again
if you like pieces of chocolate rather
than the liquid I like the liquid I add
it to my coffee we own a coffee company
called Java fit and made us
publicly-traded one of the things we do
if you I personally I don't take
anything from the company even though I
started to coming out and take anything
from it I give it all back to you guys
you know if you help other people the
more people you help the bigger your
check gets this gets good okay Harry
triple treat chocolate
a triple treat chocolate trouble treat
chocolate why is it called triple treat
because the lowers blood pressure it has
probiotics in it which gives you good
digestive stuff and gives you the best
sex life you ever had triple treat right
because it has flavanols in it to lower
blood pressure but it also has PE A's in
it Pina level means good stuff now two
of these two of these chocolates gives
you 33,000 antioxidant points 33,000
toric points which is right and a half
way mark between 20,000 50,000 these top
20 longevity people lower blood pressure
33,000 org points and PE a's I mean how
good does that get and we also have
another one called triple truffle in
addition it has 500 milligrams of usable
calcium per piece which is the size of a
pad of butter and a thousand
international units of vitamin d3 so if
you take three of those you're getting
1500 milligrams of usual calcium and
three thousand international units of
vitamin d3 which is a minimum daily
requirement for vitamin d3 no it's not
standalone product obviously you add
that to the 90 essential nutrients and
whatever else you got going so that's
sort of and I could go on with you know
main hundred and ninety-four other
diseases we don't have time for that but
you can read the book dead doctors alive
let's play doctor and so on which I go
through those diseases with you and tell
you what to do for and so what I'm going
to do now is turn this over to brandy
into Seema and Ted and they're going to
give you some information and you can
flip on the lights no well the lights
can go up and I will then answer
questions for you for about I don't know
half hour 45 minutes and we'll have a
lot of fun and save a lot of people okay
thank you very much
[Applause]